Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Nope,
man.
Milk is milk is milk is milk is
acrobatic farts.
How's that?
Acrobatic farts.
Acrobatic farms.
Acrobatic acrobatics.
Oh,
I guess it's Vegan then.
Yeah,
I guess you said so.
Yeah.
Acrobatic farts.
Let's see who,
uh,
who did that?
It's by Chris Spence is called acrobatic farts by Chris Spence.
Oh,
thank you Chris.
Thanks.
Good job jeans.
Good job.
Great jeans.
Um,
I didn't tell you this yet,
but I,
I'm editing my special and I went into the office today to do it.
Yeah.
And there's this really cute like 20 something year old girl who works the
reception desk and tits situation.
Like,
oh,
I didn't,
I didn't look at them then.
I don't wanna hear the rest of the story.
She's really sweet.
And every time I come in there,
you know,
she's got like cool pink hair.
Like she's a cool younger girl.
She's not like a dip shit basically.
Right.
And she's not overly enthusiastic or like she's,
she's smart.
You can tell.
Yeah.
So she always takes my id and checks me in.
And as I was checking in today,
um,
like a dad came in and he was signing in and then another dad came in behind her
and was like,
hey bro,
don't let him in.
I don't know.
I don't know who this guy is.
April,
don't let them in.
Don't let him in April,
April,
don't let,
and he kept repeating it and she kept ignoring him.
Yeah.
As did the guy who was signing in because we were like,
we get the joke dad and I,
I felt so bad for her cause I could see it.
She's just like this asshole.
Yeah.
We'll love it.
It's a good joke.
Yeah.
And you know,
she hears it like,
Oh
yeah.
I mean,
poor April's probably heard that
thousand 11 men,
I don't know.
This is,
yeah.
Hey,
do you see this guy?
You check them out.
Right.
All right.
And she,
she didn't
best part about her.
I love blonde jokes.
The best part is that she didn't even feign that.
It was funny.
Oh,
she's so broken by it that she was like,
yeah,
I get it.
Mark.
Or whenever it was,
it was like,
okay,
this is the a 300th day that you've done this.
But that is the plight of being an attractive young female is that Dad boners
are always cracking jokes and trying to get your attention and get you to laugh
at them because their wives hate their guts.
Probably like their children are over them.
So they,
that's why they always like to flirt with waitresses and young.
You know what it is.
I think it is.
It's not about,
it's about a tension.
Yeah.
It's about attention because their wives are like shutting it down.
Yep.
Derives,
you're in menopause.
So anyone's eyes who light up at anything.
Yeah.
Sounds exciting to them.
Cause the no law,
no eyes light up at home.
Nobody finds him funny at home.
Their kids are old enough to know that their sense of humor is one person in the
officer's like,
oh,
like mark,
you know,
like that's funny that he's like,
this is great.
It's a good feeling is great for mark.
No attention,
like nobody cares about him anymore.
It's funny because we've been,
uh,
we spent the weekend together the week together.
You've been home,
it's been great.
And we went on an overnight trip where I would say where we say,
but we want an overnight and we got to see like dad's swimming and mom's walking
around and we noticed there we were in the lobby and there was this poor son of
a bitch wearing a really baggy suit.
And then in white,
new balance.
Right.
And the pants,
first of all,
it was a,
it wasn't a suit,
it was,
it was just trousers and ah,
and a sports coat that,
but they didn't go together.
Oh,
okay.
Match.
Okay.
You know,
helping each other.
They didn't,
sure.
There was no,
you know,
unison.
The colors didn't go together and they were too short.
He had high waters on,
so they were high up
and we,
we were walking towards this guy,
what did I say?
You go,
nobody loves him.
Yeah.
He has no love.
It's going to nobody,
nobody loves him.
I even asked him,
Amanda,
my,
I didn't let him hear it,
but I go to,
does nobody love you because no one,
if somebody loved him they'd be like,
we were at,
we're going to change all of this.
Right.
Well that's the wife's job.
You got to check your spouse.
Even it's the husband's job to check the what lady?
Yeah.
So that you don't go out into the world looking like a dip shit.
He looked like a real dummy.
Yeah.
It wasn't just,
you know,
this isn't just fashion commentary.
He looked broken.
Yeah.
Well just dorky.
Like I'm not saying that I'm a Fashionista by any stretch,
but there are certain rules to the game.
Like you know the white dads sneakers and high waters is definitely not a good
look.
Not a good look.
And we were driving in the car and we saw a lady who totally shut it down
crossing the street and she was wearing what looks like those Tiva kind of
Birkenstock sandals with no socks.
You know,
we're talking about like their real utility Sandal,
the Denver Sandal and then a pair of cargo shorts.
And then like really functional looking tank top as well,
like all beige and short,
short hair.
It does,
you know there's a thing you always say is but,
and I think people will probably be like,
oh my God,
are you guys serious about this?
But I think it's true that you don't see as much of that in Europe.
I feel like,
oh absolutely not.
Uh,
growing up my mother and my stepmother kept their shit on fleek.
Yeah.
Like,
so what if he had the baby yesterday?
Like your acid going to have your manicure done,
your makeup's going to be on,
you're going to be wearing a nice dress and you're going to be back down to a
size six bitch.
Like in Europe.
It is.
I mean,
I think it is unheard of.
We were at the beach today with Lj and I see two little boys playing and the
mother and father,
I just hanging back,
there's no coolers,
there's no overwhelming toys.
Umbrellas,
the mother looks skinny,
good shape.
And I,
what I say to you,
you said,
well,
I remember when we saw some animal and you said,
I promise I'll never,
I'll never look like that animal for you.
But I,
I said,
those aren't Americans.
I go,
this is definitely not Americans anyway,
way,
there wasn't really a giveaway to that being true.
But then you talk to them and you were right.
Yeah.
The lady I talked to,
they're from Ukraine.
I knew it.
I knew it because you look great.
You're not all panicked that your kids are jumping off the rocks.
You know?
Uh,
there,
there weren't a million toys.
And you know,
Americans love to bring the whole fucking barbecue grill,
uh,
to the beach and the fucking tent and Mexican Americans.
You're saying,
I mean,
like,
I don't know.
I'm not,
I'm not specify,
but I do know that growing up my mother kept her shit tight.
Like she still looked good and she dressed like a woman.
And same with my stepmother.
Dress like a woman dressed like a woman,
not like a zero.
And I do feel like that is an American woman thing that for some reason
menopause shut up.
Shut it the fuck down.
The hormones shift.
I get it.
I totally get the,
it's hard,
especially when you have a baby,
you don't feel pretty anymore.
I will say to further that point,
I think the men in the,
in those cultures also keep it more together because you see less dad who's just
like completely let it go now that it doesn't exist obviously in those cultures,
but you see less of it,
you see less,
you see more effort put into self maintenance,
even basic fashions.
Um,
you know,
I remember in my
semester abroad when I lived with this old lady in an all in Madrid,
her son was 20 years older than me would come visit.
They do to always looked,
you know,
presentable.
He always looks sharp and he goes,
uh,
he told me,
he goes,
you didn't know how we know when an American,
he's walking down the street,
go know how he goes cause you did this like shit.
That's right.
And I was going to be,
right now I'm wearing pajamas.
Yeah,
he's like d shirts with a big stupid things on them.
Jordan's.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I was like,
oh yeah.
He's like,
that's how we know they'd say American because he looked like shit.
Yeah,
let me go.
Okay,
thanks man.
Now the flip side is that we've earned the right to look like shit cause we're
number one.
You know what I'm saying?
That is though like a result of that.
It is.
It's like,
you know what?
On the other hand,
that's our culture.
We don't give a fuck.
Fuck you.
This is my house.
This is what I do is is my Barca lounger.
Fuck you.
And I respect that too.
So I'm on both sides of the fence here.
I think it's,
I think it's a fair thing to feel both ways actually.
Because there's just times where you feel like,
Hey,
can we just fucking keep it together a little more and then there's times where
you go fuck it.
Yeah.
I'm just,
I'm just going to target.
I'm looking like shit today.
You know,
I want my house slippers out a few times in the first year of the FLS is life.
I think it's all going to do,
it's kind of a boss move.
I mean you see it a lot in la where the somebody pulls up in $100,000 car but
they were wearing t shirts and shorts and slippers.
That is like a very,
I dunno,
I,
I see that as an American thing,
right?
This is a really explicit,
like I'm not going to go out of my way to match that.
Definitely.
And uh,
specifically west coast thing.
You have west coast millionaires that look like Hobos.
Um,
a lot,
a lot.
I mean,
yes,
some of the most,
especially in show business,
like they look like fucking Douche bags and they're milling restaurants.
He runs fucking that studio and you're like,
that guy looks like shit.
It looks like he's falling apart,
man.
But I,
I think just generally,
I think,
uh,
I don't know why,
but like,
especially mothers in America,
I think there's this thing of like,
you,
you have children and now you're totally desexualized.
Like you're just an asexual.
You got to shut it down.
And it's,
it's sad.
It is sad just because I feel like European women,
there's still a sexuality thereafter.
You have children and shouldn't stop you from fucking like,
it's silly.
I'm glad that this is one of your things,
one of your hangups,
right?
You're always focused on like,
yeah,
stay fucking well,
you thinking that you're a woman because you're still a person after you have
children.
I don't know why having children makes you or the,
the culture allows you to just like,
well I'll have a kid now.
I got to shut everything down and so Zahra,
still a sexual
being.
You still person cause you have a kid.
Yeah.
You're just raising a child.
That's the thing.
It's a myth.
It's a mental shift there.
They're saying,
I have a kid,
therefore I have to give fully to this kid and all those other aspects of who I
was or I am.
I have to close up.
But you don't,
you don't have to.
No one doesn't exclude the other.
Right.
You can have a,
we can have many identities.
Yeah.
Mommy is just I,
but I think too,
that's the big mommy obsession in this country.
To that.
Moms have to be perfect and yeah,
be totally devoted 100% all the time.
Yeah,
it's a lot of pressure.
And if you don't then you're bad.
You're bad.
You're a bad mom.
Just cause you licked dad's balls.
I Dunno about that part.
I don't know about that.
Where was it?
Oh I can,
we haven't done a proper show open,
but I want you to talk about my future.
What really got it.
All right.
Let's get this show started.
Officially official,
official [inaudible] we go.
Okay.
What I want to get the message out there,
it's okay for them in the park is I'm fighting for a woman's right.
It's don't like a lot of women feel embarrassed.
They don't want a one bed and a guy like Tom,
the type of guy,
you know,
I don't mind like I'm into that stuff.
So I'm trying to get guys like me that the join this booklet because I think we
could really change the world.
Realize that the women,
there's water in their basement.
Oh is Randy.
Don't bring anyone loving to live.
Well,
welcome to your mom's house with
Christina.
I don't know.
Fucking lunatic is,
I didn't know there was a problem with women.
Bob Smith sits around Union Square in New York City filming from the cure.
Oh,
okay.
So he knows Bob is the one that's filming the people,
so he has millions of these.
This duty films in the video is named Roman.
He smells women's parts to fight for women's rights.
By the way,
I think the tie in there that I was thinking was that part of shutting it down
is,
is a result of the of feminism.
In other words,
I think for probably many years it was so unacceptable to shut it down.
That part of like backlash backlash was,
I'm going to shut it down.
I'm not doing that for you.
True.
You know it's true.
I do think that there's it and the people,
thank God people like,
like Roman are keeping women's rights,
you know,
on the table how selfless of him to sniff women's asses in public so that they
feel like they can love.
Favorite thing is when a dude who's just,
who's just trying to get a nut.
Yeah.
Changes the narrative to that.
It's a bigger thing.
Of course,
one of my favorite moves of dudes and only men are capable of spinning that type
of nonsense.
Yeah,
like dude,
you just like farts.
Yeah.
Cause it makes your Dick hard.
You don't feel like,
I don't want to change the world and write the best is a guru.
The guy who like the twin goddess activation.
Oh yeah.
Horse Shit Man guy.
He's just a fucking Douche bags and the Rob Rob Guy,
I mean he's just a guy that likes to jerk his cock and [inaudible]
all day.
They play an asshole
and this is better.
I take my time and all Spicer,
I get the snake.
The girl gives a sign in his hand.
He just says Fart smeller
that he's holding in Union Square,
which is a dad job to where they go.
He's a real fart.
Smeller I mean smart feller here though.
No,
I haven't heard that one.
But that's good.
Yeah.
Or they're not actually fighting though.
They're just putting their button,
your face.
They don't have gas.
I could just read them like the established by telling me how far is too far.
A lot of them aren't really far.
A lot of them are really farting.
Cool man.
Yeah,
he's just a perv.
It likes to sniff girl's bed.
Don't let him.
But I mean that's it
know you want to be like message out there for a woman's,
they don't what a crusader,
but we should find that song.
So I'm trying to get guys like me that the join this booklet.
I know why he says that the reason that Florida,
their face,
the reason that he says that is because it's led to it happening so many times.
In other words,
he's,
he's asked women kind of where you farmed my face and a lot of,
you know,
sometimes it's happened,
sometimes it's not.
But when he changes the narrative to empowerment,
I'm in PA,
I believe in women's rights.
I think it's ridiculous that then every once in a while somebody is like,
okay,
like he hoses them into that.
So now it's automated in his head.
Like that's what I got to say,
right.
It's positive spin on a very negative weird thing,
which I mean I congratulate him for finding that,
but it is nonsense that it's women's rights really.
Women's rights thing.
Yeah.
It's probably
make us more like my hands and was like get rid of civilization a civilization
and capitalism is a problem.
Like if we are parties,
other spaces and we get rid of the stock market back into animals.
Well wait a guy to worry about all this crap.
It's called.
We share everything.
We in college,
so this was like,
yeah,
antique.
Now it's anticapitalist.
So as he's really going out there,
it's got a bigger scope.
Tom Making a change.
Why don't you give him some credit for having that's very close minded of me to
see it that way.
Do you think he has a girlfriend?
Like what's the life like?
What's his personal life?
What I am so curious about these lunatics like what do you think is happening?
He's got it probably could have a much more fulfilling life if he wasn't so hung
up on those farts all the time.
I think it's probably,
I think it's a big distraction for him.
It's probably
a lot of his thoughts and planning and days are just in,
you know when his parents are like,
what'd you do this weekend?
He has to come up with a whole other story cause he's like,
I spent Friday planning this thing and then Saturday I,
I got to the park at at 8:00 AM and I redid my sign.
It wasn't right and then,
and then I spent about six hours.
So you're saying that it's kind of an obsessive thing with him?
I think so.
Taking over his life at this point.
I think you're right.
I think this guy should just hire someone to,
I think it's so,
he probably gets so much more done if he would just like find a woman.
If it's not a woman that he could date,
then just be like,
Hey,
do you think you could spend like a few hours just farting in?
Like I'll pay you.
You know what I mean?
Then he doesn't have money.
That's the problem.
Doesn't have money.
He doesn't have a job.
He's got another job.
Tell the fart smelling thing,
which a lot,
it's a movement and he's creating a movement baby.
But I think if he would get a job and it just hire his fart lady,
see that would be better.
You just get more done in life,
you know it is more productive.
Got To get some things done dude.
There's a lot of lady that likes like,
they like to Fart late.
We found their videos ranked well actually in this day and age maybe cause it
looked old kind of whoa.
It looks kind of old.
I would think that with the right amount of ads,
which is computer,
you know,
website ad going on,
meet people that he could,
especially like some fetish connect thing.
He could probably find someone.
I mean do you like the farm?
I like to smell him.
Sure.
He seemed Nice enough that I'm sure somebody would like him.
You know he's somebody,
he's tight.
You could have,
you could have dinner with that guy.
He's,
he,
he was a social,
now I'm not saying you,
I'm saying that like he's not so weird that you go,
look,
that guy's just fucking straight up.
Psycho is obsession now.
He,
he,
he's placing all of his eggs in this fart basket emotionally.
You know,
speaking of that,
you know,
it hasn't happened in a while.
We haven't gotten the main farther on the shot.
Let's give top dog recall.
Top Dog Kate,
buddy.
Stop.
Talk,
take buddy.
It was top dog.
You need to wipe down.
She stopped talking.
Yeah.
So let's see here.
Um,
yeah.
So on our trip,
on her overnight mommy trip,
we just took,
we heard a brand new dad joke from radio that I did radio.
It was like on,
I called in to like choppy chopper and the road dog love,
by the way,
that when I called it the radio,
they'll sometimes right before they'll tell you is in the room.
So there'll be hey,
um,
it's a,
it's a man and Mike,
just so you know,
you're on the phone with and you're like,
oh,
okay.
And this time they were like,
hey,
it's a,
it's a gym,
the ranger and Laura like,
sure.
Like it's a carrot.
I don't know who these people are,
but I mean also just to that you're going to be like,
can I talk to the ranger?
Right,
right,
right.
Like,
you know what I mean,
you're going to talk to the dog and the blood.
Yeah.
And you're like,
I'm not going to ask for Hound dog.
I'm not doing that.
And Yeah.
So anyways,
we were talking about you.
Yeah.
And it got like,
I realize it's just had a serious tone.
I was like,
you know,
we've been together and Blah,
blah blah.
And then I can tell that there's just,
they're just kind of waiting like,
what was this serious?
And then I go,
but she's got a couple of,
you know,
big old hangars owner and that's grand.
They're like,
oh,
that's awesome man.
All right.
Yeah.
Should I go?
She's got two big sloppers on her and he's like,
I love this guy.
And it was Laura here.
She's got a couple of state troopers on it.
Correct.
Which I actually think is very funny about those funny two troopers.
I've never heard that before.
I was pretty great.
That is such a great new dad joke.
I think that's really funny.
We have to run by top down.
Of course we had to get his stamp of approval on it.
Let's see,
a couple of state troopers.
Let's do,
how should we tell it?
You tell them that somebody said it or yeah,
he calls his wife's Ted State.
Drippers yeah.
Couple of Slope Dad.
Hey Buddy.
How you doing?
Good.
It's been awhile.
Yeah.
How are you man?
I'm doing good.
You know,
working half days.
It's nice.
That's nice.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
You know,
one of my buddies has a funny reference,
I don't know if you've heard this before,
but he calls his wife's boobs,
uh,
state droppers.
Call her what
he calls her boobs state droppers.
Oh my God.
I can't believe.
Oh,
it's not what I call a loving comment.
Yeah,
it's pretty funny.
Yeah.
Super Women.
You know,
they got to where they don't make bulletproof.
And what books do they not know?
What did I do?
I mean,
all right.
Are you well versed in the bulletproof vest market?
I asked one of them,
I asked one of my a and R my secretary.
You Sir?
Awesome.
To Cop.
Yeah.
Okay.
Can I address it?
They have a special model for women and she says,
I don't think so.
Oh,
all right.
Very well written.
Oh,
by the way,
an accurate,
yeah.
Uh,
so there's been a lot of excitement,
anticipation about what's going to happen with fart mistress.com the website
that I bought and yeah.
And uh,
and whether or not mom is going to fart on it.
And you know,
at first I was going to try to raise money,
but now I think what I'm going to do is just pay her myself.
But she was saying that she felt like a prostitute,
but I mean,
she don't have to get naked or anything.
You just fart.
What's the big deal?
You know,
I really don't understand.
I,
I mean,
uh,
the other day I,
I did I that tell you about that.
That shit I did the other day.
Oh God,
no,
no.
Oh,
it happened.
So,
I'm not a row,
I'm on a road trip up there.
See?
And Jane,
and what always happens when you go on a road trip is to get up in the morning.
You hit the road and I'm on the highway.
Yeah.
And if I do that,
you know,
my eight 15 bombs away time is,
doesn't happen.
So I went a whole day without a single shit.
Oh No.
Yeah,
that's really bad.
Well,
I knew what was going to happen the next day.
I know it was going to be ugly.
So woke up,
you know,
I'm home back to my normal routine county did a kind of a kind of a smaller one
probably because I don't know what that big,
and then driving to the gate of the,
uh,
where we live and all of a sudden I feel it coming and I know that feeling.
And I said,
Oh my God,
am I gonna make it?
So you were on your way in or out?
I don't know.
He entered the subdivision.
Okay.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
headed down there and then you know,
you know that feeling when you have to go,
you have to kind of squeeze your cheeks together.
You have to stretch your legs out.
Yeah.
How far are you from the house as you're feeling this?
Oh,
I'm,
you know,
quarter mile.
Okay.
So I'll make a lefthand turn down our street,
pull in the driveway,
but then I got to get out of the car,
you know,
the,
I got to keep my teeth together.
Yes.
I'm getting out of the car and the whole idea is,
you know,
to try to run in there
and make that right turn.
And when I made that right turn,
uh,
you know,
some of it just slipped out what
some of the shed came,
came out and I didn't want to got down the toilet.
Oh yeah.
You know,
it was really messy.
I had some,
in fact it was so messy that I had to wipe,
I know normally do this,
but I had some on my left cheek.
I had to,
you know,
white,
my left cheek with my left hand.
I mean,
you know.
Wow,
that's an
unorthodox.
It feels different,
right?
To use your,
well it does.
It's very unorthodox.
And then,
then I looked down to my underwear and I can see some shit to basically,
I had a few,
you know,
niblets in my underwear.
Then I looked inside my trousers and some of it fell into inside my,
so do you throw that stuff away?
What do you do with that?
Oh,
oh no,
no,
I just
rent it off in the,
uh,
in the Andrea when you just rent it often and you know,
why would you,
why wouldn't you just throw the underwear out?
Well,
why should we,
it's perfectly good.
Unaware.
Not Anymore.
It's not,
it's covered in shit.
Listen,
listen,
I,
I know a lot about,
you know,
sunset and your pants kind of stuff and thanks a lot more of that too.
We on a good pair of underwear.
What does it mean?
What would it take to ruin a good pair of underwear?
Mostly one of the elastic gets worn out.
I mean,
so if you had like a full,
if you've got a full shit in your pants,
you'd still keep them.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I what I do is take a shit and put it in the toilet and rents the rest of it and
they handle all
this and that be,
and then you know,
you're just recycle.
So listen,
good underwear away.
That's not good anymore.
That's the whole point.
Well it is good once you want you to put it in washing machine and hot water and
soap and it comes out nice and white or blue,
whatever color.
Yeah.
Right.
Another episode.
No,
you should just try to tell you
the,
the issue here really for me was I have to,
when I,
when I really got to go,
I got to work on making those turns into the bathroom or you got to work on
that.
Yeah.
Cause I made that turn and of course means you put your legs and when you make
that turn,
that's when my
turn,
are you talking about though?
Going from in the house to the bathroom.
So through the laundry room.
Yeah,
there was a laundry.
I'm going,
I gotta turn rights.
Closest bathroom,
you know,
is a guest bathroom shower after that?
Oh yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
After.
Yeah,
it was,
I had to,
it was such a mess.
I had jumped in the shower.
And
what's up with the,
uh,
I'm just changing the topic because I'm about to puke in my mouth,
but what do you,
are you into those new Bra,
new bras mom?
Got,
or are you still digging those?
Are you not mean you're not liking those anymore?
Okay.
Well,
I'm a lace ma'am.
Okay.
Yeah,
I always like to see through,
you know,
give a little little
see through there and see that Nepal's and other things.
I'm always been a lace guy and you know,
these functional lift bras with,
if there had been my,
my favorites,
but you know,
I'm not going to tell her that.
Is she wearing,
what is she wearing now?
The functional ones.
Oh yeah,
she,
she's all functional night.
Yeah.
But why don't you just get her some lace ones?
Just she'll wear,
but
she doesn't want,
she did,
but she likes to functional.
Um,
yeah,
know.
So
I was telling,
uh,
I was telling Christina about this girl I went out with in college once,
who,
she had such a full Bush that it looked like she had a pair of balls when she,
when she had her panties on,
it was like too much.
Well,
you know,
my generation,
it was all about the bush.
Oh,
my generation.
The girl never shaved.
And you would classify women by nationality,
whether they had big Bush,
a little Bush.
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So basically you're Italian,
you're Greek.
You know,
Julie at black,
black bushes,
Scandinavians,
you're,
you know,
uh,
the head,
you know,
grade level and what and,
and,
and the Irish to death,
the English,
you never knew what you were going to get with that.
I mean,
it was all over the map,
but the big ones right there,
the big,
the big black bushes where there,
you know,
that kind of lower European Mediterranean.
Well,
that's what this girl was.
She was a Portuguese.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I can,
I can imagine.
Yeah.
I mean,
I saw those panties and I go,
I'm about to hook up with a guy right now.
Well,
I'll tell you,
some of those girls in those days,
they did partial shaves because,
you know,
they,
they would,
it would almost be like he a,
uh,
like a reverse triangle,
you know,
would kind of,
the hair would kind of go up towards,
enables the girls would,
would shave themselves.
Parsons.
Oh,
like from below the navel because it would grow and we grow up so high.
Oh yeah.
You couldn't wear a bikini otherwise.
Oh,
I see.
Yeah.
That's very common in our generation.
This girl had a lot of hair,
a small penis,
but a lot of hair.
She had a small penis,
I'm so thrilled.
Yeah.
But I haven't had an accident like that time in a long time.
Uh,
uh,
I feel like,
I feel like it's happened a few times in the last year though.
I feel like it's not that.
Yeah,
it's all,
do you know the,
it's all due to when I travel on the car,
what happens is,
you know,
when you get up,
you're,
you're not in your routine.
You eat differently in the morning coffee,
you know,
you're on the road and then for some reason it just stays there in your rectum.
I know I have a lot of travel day problems,
you know,
travel day affects,
I don't know how you'd do it,
quite frankly.
I mean,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm getting,
I'm getting teeth whitened,
uh,
the week after next.
Um,
you want me to set you guys up?
You're out here.
Your mother would want me to get my teeth whitened.
Yeah.
Are you opposed to that?
No,
I'm not.
I just don't want it to be so white,
but it makes me look like,
you know,
I'm kind of Christmas decoration.
Oh,
I hope it does.
I'm going to take,
that's going to be my gift to you if you come out in the next few months.
Yeah.
We're,
we're working on that Thanksgiving thing.
Okay.
So,
okay.
All right.
That'd be great.
Look,
I gotta run.
I love you.
Let me talk to you later.
Okay,
bye bye.
And that was pretty much amazing.
I didn't know about the lacy Bra that he likes to see that sample and we would
classify him.
Still crushes.
Okay.
That is so gross.
How does it feel to know your dad's sexuality and his sexual preference?
And more than I need.
It's more than 98.
Do you feel like you want to marry your dad?
No.
So Gross,
right?
Yeah.
How come?
It's never okay to know your parents sexual stuff even when you're like a 40
year old grown ass man.
I Dunno.
Never want to know.
Want to hear about it.
What gives your dad a heart on?
No,
he gets more comfortable with it with age cause we'll be hanging out like a bad
Shayne's gun.
She didn't take care of you.
All right.
And the SAC.
Okay.
Her over there?
Uh,
yeah,
that she would capitalist state troopers.
Okay.
All right.
Well you have to remind him about that when he's out here so that he starts
saying it more.
I feel like he could really adapt that.
He would love to introduce that to his friends.
That's what I'm saying.
You just need some reminders.
We need to drill him on it and then hell yeah,
he'll take it back to Florida.
You know,
we made love recently and it was great,
but I was thinking there's always room to improve,
so we're going to talk about one of the scariest parts of that initial dating
experience and that's the first kiss.
We're going to talk a little bit about the first guest and then we're going to
talk a little bit about some of the advanced kissing.
Is this real?
This is real.
This is really one of the things that's really cool about kissing.
We always have learned to kiss when we're both giving and receiving at the same
time,
but actually an amazing way to kiss is just to give or just to receipt.
No,
boy,
that's true.
What do you think?
That's Joanna
and she's just going to receive my kiss.
Just start there.
I hate watching people kiss.
She's not kissing back.
Yes.
So,
and she's feeling all of my energy that we talked about in the touch exercise
and the sensation of the sophos.
My Lips against her.
How was
great.
He looks like such a fucking dad.
Total boner.
But this is not what's called being a bad kisser.
When you're just limp and you don't respond well,
they're advanced.
So maybe not their intimacy experts and feel like she's making out with her a
golf coach or something.
He's super lame.
Did
well he can't,
he's not cool at net.
Neither a she,
but like,
he's super boners like he's not even,
he's not even trying.
I can gave up.
Huh?
I Dunno.
He just seems like such a fucking manager of the,
of the,
you know the Gla sunglasses shot.
Yeah.
Such a four corners team,
but
all right,
so there's a lot of things you can do.
You have a whole playground around lips.
You have the outer part of the limps you have in it.
This is real.
You have upper lip,
lower lip,
which feel entirely different.
Yeah,
absolutely.
How you know that you fucking nerd.
Yeah.
You dorks,
you can use your lips to kiss.
You can use the one throw up.
Sure.
Tony to kissing.
You can do all this just on the outer lips before we even go inside.
She can just slick your banner on.
There you go.
I got to say,
I got a ponytail guy right here.
How was that?
That was good.
I got uncomfortable watching that scene in billions when they,
when uh,
when they show
perceived real fucking show or movie time loves to do that.
By the way,
Jesus,
showtime will always open on an uncomfortable sexing.
Yeah,
but that guy,
the star of billions has a weird mouth.
He does.
He was a,
he played agent Brody,
Brody Stevens,
Steven,
Bertie,
Siemens,
even Brody Stevens from homeland.
He played the red haired guy that Claire Danes,
you know,
subway,
whatever.
But his mouth is just so hard there a name for that to get over.
I called Bert mouth or something
where they have like the shape of the teeth is weird.
Burt mouth.
Yeah.
You know,
who else has a mouth like that?
Um,
Bill Walton,
you know that it is.
And of course you don't look at this.
You have so much disdain for my lack of sports knowledge.
No.
Yeah.
But I don't care about sports.
Why would I know this guy is such a door,
he doesn't get laid at all.
Who's doing the intimacy expert?
Let's see here.
Why would you pay money for these two doors to do it?
Whoa.
Look at those teeth,
but see how the chompers or unusually large,
the shape,
the shape is kind of similar.
Yeah.
Not Good.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
but I'm saying his lips,
Adrian Brody Stevens lips is weird.
Oh God.
The teeth are all wrong.
And there were all fake.
So he should have had them done smaller.
Yeah,
but he's always had that.
I mean,
that's the shape of his mouth.
You know,
he has that,
what's that guy's name?
They have the same mouth.
No.
Yeah,
it's similar,
but his lips are not
where the teeth start to go back is sooner.
So in other words,
the mouth goes is more in the teeth are more narrow than wide.
Okay.
Look up per agent.
Brody.
Ancient.
Okay.
Look at billions.
Yeah.
Just Google billions to star and so people know what we're talking about.
But his lips are weird.
I'm just saying the shape of his without his mouth open.
Even I,
the lips really put me off.
Yeah.
Plus he's a,
he's a red hair guy.
It's not my,
it's not my lane.
Damian Lewis,
he's a great actor.
He's,
I think New Zealand or Kiwi or bread or whatever.
Does he not know or Australian or mom's Chilean.
He does the American accent flawlessly as English.
He can't even tell the guys English.
Yeah.
Yup.
Cause she,
he and the wife were fucking in their pool,
which by the way,
I don't know who has sex in a pool because all the water goes up your vision and
it's so uncomfortable.
It's bullshit.
Yeah.
His mouth looks super weird,
but it looks weird or when it's closed as lip,
sir.
Yeah.
See,
see the shape of it.
It's like he's such a great actor and his mouth always bothered me in homeland.
It's probably bothered him a lot too.
Yeah.
But he's like,
he's gotten,
I mean for having a weird mouth.
Yeah.
He's a really confident,
weird mouth guy.
See how he was talking about they go back.
Yup.
As opposed to wide,
right?
Yeah.
So the,
and that's what Bill Walton has.
So you're saying they got it.
It's like a,
it's like a smiley shape or something on teeth.
Yeah.
So Weird,
Huh?
Yeah.
It's like it's,
that's what's what it is.
No,
I know those are,
but the teeth,
they also went way too big on those veneers,
man.
You gotta be careful with those veneers.
Those are huge.
There's donkey.
Yeah.
By the way,
what if we get my dad to get really,
really,
really white tea and veneers to like super white donkey when you're so fucking
hard.
Yeah.
Well I'm just thinking when's the last time your dad went to the dentist all oh
yeah,
I know.
We will.
We could ask that.
And it's been a while.
It has been awhile cause your sisters are always so mean to him about his
breath.
I was like,
God,
your breath.
And they shove like gum in his mouth all the time.
Oh yeah,
your Dad's got the worst dad mouth.
Total dad mouth.
Yeah,
he's got total total fucking dad mouth.
Is it that the dads just don't brush their teeth at all?
Is that what happens?
Or just being old.
Alright,
so there's a lot,
a lot of things you can do.
You have a whole playground around.
You have outer part of the lips,
you have inner part of the lips,
upper lip and the women,
which feel entirely different apps.
I'm gonna throw up that these tools are fucks to kiss.
You can use one that we're doing is we're kissing with their eyes open,
that maintain energy and there's a connection of our hearts.
There's the connection of our lips,
there's the connection of our eye.
Here's why.
That's his bullshit.
We just dance.
Your eyes open is also how someone who has never kissed before cause then
they're trying to say this is an advanced.
If you,
if you have two eighth graders make out,
they're going to go like [inaudible] and one of them is going to be like close
your fucking eyes.
Weird.
Basically what they're giving you is like rookie kissy moves and they're saying
that it's advanced.
It's not advanced,
not advanced.
This is fucking,
you're right.
It's like,
yeah,
new and you're kissing and using your breath.
Knowing that can happen.
We can actually even knew about it.
It is weird to watch people do
got it.
If someone did that to me,
I would vomit if someone,
and that's the thing is that I would laugh.
Yeah,
it's intentionally trying.
It's trying hard to be sexy.
Like I was watching the show Gypsy on Netflix,
two guns say guides again.
Donald's a mirror.
It's not about them though.
Just see now and Naomi Watts is making out with this girl,
this younger girl,
and she goes,
I want you to dance for me.
And the girl does it and it's so corny.
And we were just,
we're making fun of it last night.
And I was like,
Tom,
I want you to dance for me.
Like who does that?
Like who can do it with a serious face?
People that aren't assholes.
That's the thing is we're too jaded to do.
Is that right?
Yes,
of course.
But I feel like that will be taking myself way too seriously by the way.
Told you about the tongue lead kisser.
Yeah.
I'm like,
they're telling you to do that.
These dorks.
It was terrible.
I thought that was some juvenile shit.
This is like a,
a woman I went out with a few times and every time like even if you were like,
uh,
okay,
so I'll see you later.
And you gave a kiss.
She would put her tongue in your mouth.
Yeah,
we,
no,
you mean she would leave with her tongue?
Right.
So she's sticking her tenant like what they're telling you to do?
Like you,
well just,
I mean it's,
it's for us like what you would expect to be just a,
not a make out kiss,
just a peck goodbye.
Goodbye or good.
I picked you up like good to see you.
You'd feel the tongue come into your mouth.
And I was like,
I don't know.
I can't get over this.
Who does she,
I remember telling people I worked with,
I was like,
I don't think I can get over this cause I don't know how to bring it up.
Yeah.
How do you bring that up to send?
It wasn't a one time.
This was,
oh,
so it was like an accident.
Like I know we went out probably four or five times and every time she gave you
a hello and goodbye kiss,
it was tone.
Every single kiss had tongue.
Every single one.
Yeah.
Do you think that she just had it out there,
let you know how parakeets,
like they always have their tongue kind of,
it was just always out.
I,
I think that she,
my interpretation was she thought this is super sexy.
Uh,
she's training me and an expert intimacy person,
not a novice like us.
And I was more like,
you don't,
I mean,
you can pull you in,
pull that in sometimes.
Yeah.
I mean,
imagine,
imagine if every kiss a tongue was going into,
I don't like too much.
It's too much time.
I don't like math.
I ended up having anxiety about her kisses.
Oh,
of course.
Yeah,
I don't even like mouth kissing.
Um,
friends.
Goodbye.
Yeah.
Uh,
or Myra has a,
my son,
I think it's more with women.
I have had women friends where there's definitely,
there was nothing there sexually.
They're married or they're,
they're in relationships and they're happy and they greet with mouth kisses.
That's what I'm saying.
And how you,
uh,
now with women,
but with men,
male friends and I'm like,
I went and I kind of have to term like I go for the change.
So guys,
we'll lead with it.
Yeah.
See I've never,
I've never obviously never done it to me.
I didn't know that men would lead with it.
Yeah.
It's like a,
it's an la thing.
a hipster,
it's like a cool la person thing.
Really.
If you're cool,
you do a mouth case,
which I don't do,
I don't kiss because now it's like a,
it's like a cool person that I see you [inaudible] yeah.
Yeah.
I mean the last time it felt to me like it was kind of a cool but high society
thing was it was elite people that I,
that I encountered doing that or,
and it always was so jarring to be like,
Whoa,
what'd you just do?
I like that.
I told you I,
I had friends in high school who the whole family kissed on the mouth.
The Sun would kiss the dad's mouth.
The mother would kiss the son's mouth,
the little girl,
the sister would kiss the brother's mouth,
the dad and the,
and the sign would kiss on the mouth.
Like what?
And he was like 17 years old.
A bike at night,
goodbye guys.
Everybody's mouth kissing in the whole family.
There's a lot.
Super Weird.
I tell you the one time,
and I brought this up on the show like many years ago.
One time I was kissing my stepdad goodbye any turned his head just as I was
going for his cheek and we and I kissed like the corner of his mouth.
Like I've been thinking about it for 20 years.
That's how long ago that he got to say something then or no,
no.
It was just like,
ugh.
But you think about it like,
Ugh,
that one time I corner mouth kiss my stepdad gross.
That's gross.
That would make me uncomfortable.
Mouth Kiss your mom.
Your ever cause your mom,
Huh?
It's just like the gaze is just like the gate.
No,
no growth.
I don't want mouth kisses.
Not from your family or strangers.
I even our son,
I feel weird.
I feel like that's not okay.
Mouth Kissing a boy,
kiss their children.
And I know a lot of people do it to small kids.
I think that it's not too crazy.
But what happen when the boys like 12 or you still mouth kissing your son?
Probably.
I'm not sure.
That's okay.
You want to give mommy kiss on the mouth.
What else did they have?
The intimacy experts.
These two are the other.
That's how it's done.
We saw how we kind of move back and forth and I would pause and then Joanna
would pause.
I would pause.
And when you feel the other person pause and you know that's your cue to take
lead and you need the kids for a while,
dance with it.
And he can play inside,
outside,
slowly moving your tongue or you didn't see your teeth just in a gentle way,
but you can do so much and you can feel the energy
to be at this.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Would you rather,
would you rather
come on?
You don't even listen.
Okay.
Would you rather,
would you rather a burning man?
We go to burning man for two weeks and you're two weeks.
You're not showering.
You've got the Playa dust,
you've got playa dust in your asshole and your eyes and your beard.
Uh,
you're taking shits and Porta potties.
It's a 120 degrees during the day.
You know me?
Well,
uh,
there's,
there's vagina eating contests.
There's just dirty hippies everywhere.
Or it's two weeks of the intimacy class
I can't do at burning man for two weeks,
two weeks a one if it's one week each.
What if I shorten the time?
Um,
everything about burning man is what I hate.
Or Coachella.
This doesn't start Coachella or to at least entertain me.
I'd be more entertained by intimacy class.
This will be,
but the,
it's the intimacy that makes me uncomfortable because then there'll be like Tom
and Christina,
you guys try it in front of everybody and then I'd be like,
oh,
I know,
but I would be laughing and I'd like that.
There's air conditioning and there's a bathroom.
All that really bothers me about those festivals.
Burning man in particular because it's playa dust.
You're out on a Applia,
whatever.
And they all had some,
some fucking idiot that listens to our show.
Messaged me about.
He's like,
when did you become like,
like such a bitch about crowds?
Oh,
always like we talking about.
Yeah.
And also,
I never understand when somebody like upset about you not liking something that
they like.
Yes.
Like why the fuck do you think that that's a logical point to bring up?
Hey Man,
I festivals.
How can you not like fast?
Well,
I'm not you.
You dumb.
Fuck.
Yeah,
I know.
He uh,
he has to have everybody agree with him.
Why would it in the world?
We all have to like the same things,
but they're obviously,
there are scores of people who love burning man,
love Coachella and many more who don't.
It's just not for us.
Yeah,
of course.
Not My scene,
man.
I'm a fucking adult.
I can't do that crap.
Somebody,
I'm an adult message this,
this was pretty grown ass woman.
I don't sit in my own filth for a week like an Asshole,
you know?
Here we go.
Look at this.
Hold on.
Email.
Hey mommies.
I was talking to my wife about our weight loss.
I for completely forgot what inspired me to change my life.
In the summer of 2014 I weighed just over 500 pounds.
Wow.
I was always the big funny guy.
I love comedy.
One night after work,
my wife and I decided to watch Tom's special.
Well,
as you know,
you have a bit about how you shouldn't have diarrhea every day and Mommy,
Tina offers a ride to the hospital.
This is 100% true.
By the way.
That bit is based on reality.
You came out,
we were in silver lake and you came out and I go,
do you need to go to the hospital and that line is in the vet.
I mean that's the real line.
That shit was the funniest thing I've ever heard.
I remember thinking,
Haha,
only.
Oh my God,
that's totally true.
That's me.
Oh my God.
That is me.
It was the only statement that actually broke through my fat head.
And now I'm down 225 pounds.
Wow.
My wife joined me soon after she's lost 125 pounds together.
We've lost half a burnt Chrysler.
Wow.
I made this true.
So thank you.
You're coming to does a lot more than make people laugh.
I haven't gotten updated before and after and over a year.
But here's some proof.
Next time you're in Columbus,
come over for some Mousse to
look this guy.
This is the early,
so here he's over five bills.
How man here?
He's lost 225 pounds.
Congratulations Jane.
That is really something men.
That is really amazing.
Congratulations to you.
Wow,
that was really great.
I don't see,
is your name in here?
No.
So I don't know who said this,
but you obviously know who you are.
If you send it and uh,
we congratulate you.
That's amazing.
Speaking of Moose Soup,
Send Lucy,
my God,
people have gone bananas for move Soup Lady.
Uh,
we can get into some of that and we did it because you asked us to allot asked
us,
here it is.
Come down for moose soup shirt on sale.
Go to merchant method.com/tom Segura and you will see a,
uh,
the moose soup lady.
A shirt.
Who designed that?
This was,
this was submitted to us by Andrew [inaudible].
So thank you Andrew for submitting this design.
Yep.
We saw it and fell in love with it.
And this is it.
Garden down.
Thank you Andrew.
It's a really cool design.
Yeah,
they are fully stocked all the sizes.
I want to thank everybody also who obviously supports the show in so many ways,
but I wanted to thank everybody that ordered that special edition sub cane
shirt.
Um,
those started going out and then the,
the mostly stories signed vinyl.
I went back and signed a hundred more of them because of those went out as well.
I was so surprised that people are ordering vinyl.
I'd never done it.
Here's how many they,
um,
there was such a demand for it that,
uh,
I got completely normal.
The first special on vinyl.
Uh,
it'll go out next month,
so I'll let you know when those arrive.
But yeah,
there's making fitness.
Everybody's been super supportive of our store and it,
it totally helps,
uh,
support this show.
So thank you guys for doing that.
I'm down later for move soup.
So I've found the moose suit lady faced and I'm obsessed with her and I love
her.
Yeah,
she really sells moose soup.
You know that it's her thing.
It's her singing at a party.
Moosup lady singing.
Okay.
Is that voice the voice?
It's civil.
I best part is actually not seen.
Exactly.
It's hearing her.
You don't need to see her.
I mean she looks like how you imagine.
Let's just put it that way.
Like she looks like that person.
They don't know
quite a voice.
Yeah.
Jackson Jackson.
This is actually somebody who I'm better suited to impersonate than you are and
it's a woman,
but my natural,
yeah.
Voice is
about
Jackson.
Okay.
How do you get that voice?
It starts to,
cause here's the thing.
I have a pretty deep lady voice.
Do you think in 20 years I could get moose soup,
lady voice.
Um,
I dunno,
but I'd have to start smoking again.
I Dunno if this is a sure.
I,
no,
it's somebody else's.
Um,
yeah,
there's a lot of smoking involved,
but I have to start smoking again.
Yeah.
Here she is a,
this is my,
another good one.
Just and it's on like a blue Jay.
Can you add on the water?
Small boats.
I mean there's barn
too loud.
Two lines.
Two at a horrible,
yeah,
the,
it's too,
that doesn't work,
but you get the idea.
It's those types of,
it's really her.
It's all her.
It's all real.
Yeah.
It moves soup.
She sells Musu.
It's on,
she has a garage sale right now.
She just knows about a garage sale and she's like,
I have moved to bread.
Dinner Rolls.
I Dunno.
She posted the phone number.
That's crazy.
Guys do not,
if you find her,
please leave her alone.
Don't,
yeah.
Don't we don't want to interrupt this.
She's a normal person living a life flake.
Let's not
mass with says Musu,
but she's just,
she's a bad ass dude.
She's,
Oh,
she,
it says that she's a,
a professional cook.
Oh,
wow.
Yeah.
So maybe she does make amazing new soup,
you know?
That's cool.
Well,
next time we're in Alaska,
we should look her up.
She's single,
not too,
there you go.
Yeah.
What'd you date?
The Musubi Lady?
No,
I think at this time in my life it's not appropriate.
Why?
I'm younger.
Maybe wait a little while.
How long is this your,
is this your wife?
[inaudible] I don't think,
what does my wife after me like again?
So we had this discussion.
Who,
you and Mary after me,
like your second wife and I was like,
you're probably gonna.
Well,
I think,
I think you should point out that at first I suggested,
I was like,
oh,
I could see it being like a Latin guy.
And you're like,
yeah.
And I go,
you're like a Brazilian or something?
And you're like,
oh,
I could see that.
So it was like,
that's what I set up to you.
I was like,
I could see that being your next go.
Brazilian.
I Love Portuguese.
Yeah.
And that's how the hearing you were like,
Oh that is neat.
And then you go,
I go,
what about me?
And you said,
and I go,
I see you with some
nasty porno chick,
like some girl who's like,
I'm going to fucking piss on your balls.
And then when I put a baseball bat in my ass,
like stuff like that.
That's what I see you with.
Okay,
cool.
That's really cool.
But hear me out.
Hold on because
I see you with somebody like that because you know you did like the good family
guy thing on our,
our marriage,
like we're doing the kid and the dogs and like a normal existence and who knows?
You might get so famous that reality gets distorted like it does with a lot of
really famous guys.
You can be that guy,
you know,
pushing your dick through a wire fence to get it sucked.
And then I,
you know what I mean?
That's not weird.
And then you can be like,
I'm so sick of this boring wife and kid lifestyle.
Yeah.
I got to get with
the girl at pencils on my balls.
That's going to happen.
Why did she piss on my balls?
So you like it is because you've been repressing your savage desire?
Yes,
Trish and Bobby,
they have a pretty good sex life.
Like we have a pretty consistent thing here and I Bobby or attrition Bobby.
But I know what I mean.
Like I feel like you're going to have some real deviant shit coming out later in
life,
man.
Yeah.
Oh Gee.
You told me as long as it's later in life.
It's cool though.
You're like,
Oh,
after like 20 years you can put that,
oh,
once our kid is in college.
Yeah,
you want a divorce?
Fine.
But let's,
no,
you said we stay together,
but I can be like,
oh yeah,
I want to go get my balls that's licensed to do that stuff.
That's not what I meant.
Now,
if,
if we,
I like you so much as a person.
If in 20 years we fucking like the marriage is just not working.
Yeah.
Well maybe we still live together like the French do.
Oh,
okay.
but we have you have your paramour?
No.
Okay.
But I like you.
That's this.
That's what I'm saying.
Like I like to stay married.
I want you to,
I don't know why you think I'm going to go get my balls,
pistols cause that's okay.
I know you,
I just,
I feel like that's going to be your next thing.
Like my next thing is getting my balls pissed on.
Okay.
All right.
Um,
well it will be joined by the Great Yoshi Obayashi here in just a few minutes.
Take a quick break and we'll be back with him.
O M G and we're back and we're joined by one of the all time.
Great guys and your mom's house podcast.
Yoshi.
Obayashi
thanks guys.
It's your song
dude.
Absolutely.
Thanks for,
it's always good to see you.
Last time we saw you think was at the live show.
Yeah.
Ryan sperm in California.
But that,
I think the last time I did a show at your place,
it's been a couple of years when you were in the old students.
Like our old place.
Yeah.
By the beach area.
Long time ago.
We've had two studios since,
right,
Tom?
Yeah.
One,
two.
And this is the third one.
So we just,
yeah.
And actually if you want to add up all the different rooms we've done it in.
There's that,
there's the first room and silver lake.
Yeah.
Oh that's right.
Oh Gee.
Smile.
That's the,
but then the beach.
Yup.
Room.
Then the beach office I went to.
Yeah,
he did that one too.
Then the rental house.
Yeah.
And then here,
so there's five total rooms.
I know.
Let's help.
This one stays for awhile.
Oh my God.
Like a sports franchise finding.
You guys got a real,
I mean,
real really fancy.
Yeah.
This is a real place to do it in men.
So it's,
um,
it's always good to see you,
man.
It's good.
I'm glad you could come here.
Alright.
Okay.
So
you would have to be here.
I know you've been,
you've been doing a lot of things,
man.
You were,
were you in Europe you said?
Right?
And recently,
yeah.
But before your fans are so,
I mean,
there's just so cool.
Love you.
You're,
you're,
you're a home run with it.
When it comes to our fans in this show,
they're very,
very kind.
And He,
Dave,
we'll even show up in some shady dive bars.
I couldn't believe it.
Really?
Yeah,
they're always coupling and no matter how,
how much of a horrible thing I see in stage,
they're,
they're just so,
and you're good at that.
You say some horrible,
horrible thing.
Yes.
I'm going to do the last show.
This lady,
I think the tail end of the show your fans over there.
[inaudible] she said,
I laugh at every joke you,
I even left at Joe 15 joke.
But when you make jokes by age,
my brother died 25 years ago and she was very upset with me.
When people are upset,
I let them say whatever they paid.
So,
and um,
how does it affect you when they,
when they're,
when they are upset and does it,
does it affect you in some way though?
Cause it,
I mean I'm at,
believe it or not,
I do have feelings,
but I like the,
I don't want to get into the detail,
but there's not,
not once have ounce of malice net joke.
It was trying to make it
totally believe you.
I,
I'm trying to make people be sympathetic way.
How do you handle her?
Like when she says I'm a very upset and she's done saying it.
Do you say something in response?
Like I let her,
I don't interrupt.
I let her say it because this is not,
she was trying to get attention.
She was genuine in her and she was hearing me say horrible stuff.
She was a all the way with me for the tail end of it.
I let her speak on away and she got her staff,
she got out and she said that she closed the door.
And I said,
but I have 20 more h jokes for you.
And if people laugh,
but um,
situation like that,
you,
you should let them say whatever.
I'm okay with that.
Um,
and I think this is something that I face a lot in Sweden.
You know,
I remember saying something about women,
they literally,
they take jokes,
literally dig it upset without not knowing the intention.
Would that make sense to you?
But what I also tell them,
like,
I don't have a problem when you speak in during the show.
Uh,
and uh,
that's okay with me.
But when you do that,
you're basically saying everyone in the room have no rights to hear what I have
to say because people jumped to conclusion about right.
So,
but I tell you,
I don't think this is just me and there's a lot of comedians are facing this
like a couple of weeks ago when bill mark,
I'm in trouble for that joke.
Uh,
he's been very supportive minorities,
you know,
um,
I listened to that joke.
He used an anywhere.
I don't think it was malicious at all and people are just overreacting.
Well,
it was a pretty big reaction.
I think,
you know,
people,
he,
um,
he got bigger issues,
a institutionalized,
I can't even say that racism and young black kids getting shot and those are the
bigger issues.
I got a joke.
Not a joke.
Yeah.
I think,
I think he did do that thing where it's like him saying that joke.
If he were like hanging out with like in a room,
yeah.
Would be,
people would laugh and have no like with him if he was with comics for sure.
Right.
Um,
but doing it on TV,
it's like,
it's one of those things where I think people interpret it as,
it's not so much the joke.
Yeah.
But they're going youth,
you think you have a pass.
Right.
Why do you think that's what a lot of people were taking it,
right?
Yeah.
Like why do you get to say that?
You know?
And also people who are,
who are not a fan of his,
and I don't want you to comedy.
Yeah.
When they see a small clip on youtube,
they just make all this assumption now knowing,
believe me,
he has done a lot of good things out there.
I'm a fan and especially where the drug policies,
you know,
he's,
he's so spend finding the joy for it.
Yeah.
So,
but we live in the PE.
People are gonna attack you no matter what.
Absolutely.
Well,
and I think people have always,
there's always been these assholes,
assholes,
people who are offended at everything.
And it used to be that you had to call the television station and now you can
just immediately get outraged on Twitter.
You can reach,
but you can tweak Bill Maher himself right now.
He knows who's mad at him.
It's the immediacy of communication too,
I think.
I don't know.
Yeah.
So anyway,
you know,
she mentioned that you're doing some medical testing lately,
right?
Are you doing,
did you just say that you were finishing something?
I finished one and three months ago and probably going to do another one.
Um,
late next month it's going to be 36 days.
I haven't qualified 36 day.
Yeah,
this one's on a minute.
What are you doing?
I don't know.
The drug spend,
like I always say,
I only have ancient Monday pay,
so they just like,
is it paying a fortune 12,
almost 13 granite?
Think that's pretty good.
Oh,
I think the saying is how long is the stay?
How much is the pay?
What are you,
do you know what they're going to be testing?
No,
but,
uh,
I,
I don't really care per se.
Most of them only do they care about is if it's anything to do with deep brain
related,
like if you have a bipolar or any of those kind of mental medications,
I will not touch those.
But cancer,
uh,
I dunno.
Um,
Alzheimer's.
You've gone for all of it?
Yeah,
I've done it.
Yeah.
Send a problem.
What will they do to you in 36?
What will they do to you in 36 days?
This is what typically usually happened.
Um,
I'm not even considering my taking the medication,
so it's,
I'm always like,
everyone is starving because they cut down on your calorie.
Like I got as low as one 16 last studies I brought back again,
like 17 pounds by already know.
Once I going for 36 days,
I'm going to drop at least 20 to 25 pounds.
So it's like a diet for you too.
That's the biggest reason I'd rather lose weight.
Yeah.
That's my number where I need to lose weight,
that I'm too lazy to lose.
When I mean you did an amazing job.
I mean look,
I lost some weight.
Yeah,
I lost you look great.
Thanks buddy.
I mean I lost 50 pounds
and I've kept it off.
I actually lost a couple more pounds since the a way in.
Yeah.
It's good cause you know,
I mean you have a wine,
but most importantly you have a child,
you know,
and some of my are,
I don't want to mention names,
but some of the comedian's friend of mine,
they're overwhelmed.
I'm just worried about their kids more now.
Russell.
Yeah.
Hi.
Oh sorry.
By the way,
when I saw Peter say he'll,
he'll want to do podcasts that love to have him Europe.
So I was there.
You don't know.
You don't know what you're,
sorry.
You don't know what you're getting into for this next.
No.
Can you find out what the drug is and can you pull the plug on it?
Like if they show up and you show up and it's something you don't want to do,
can you say no and leave or,
sure.
So basically when you have a,
like I got,
I just emailed him like I'm running out of money.
So that's when I usually email them and then they'll still me.
These are the following studies.
So we have,
and then above that that I just love the,
the system for you.
Like I'm running out of money.
What,
what medical tests do you have going on?
There's like four or five different facilities in southern California.
And this one,
this guy always email me back right away because they're always afraid.
Even if they pass the screening,
they go in after five 60 they can't do anymore.
They just lose their mind.
Cause you,
you can leave,
you know,
and you're hungry.
You're hands are shaking because no coffee and caffeine,
all the tests dictate low calorie intake.
Like no matter what you're going,
no.
So Ds,
Ds business.
Okay.
So every pharmaceutical companies make drugs to me trying to make profit.
Billions of dollars in profit,
right?
Yeah.
But it's hit and miss.
Um,
but they don't have a drug to be tested every day.
So they have another,
another business called Cro,
clinical research organization.
All they do is they get contacted by a pharmaceutical company and say,
Hey,
we have x medication.
We'd like to test it on people and we need 40 people between this age at this
body mass index.
And they kind of be a smoker.
So they have all kinds of different criteria for each medication based on each
pharmaceutical company.
So since there's some studies,
we could drink coffee.
Great.
There's other studies where you could do,
you could do almost anything now there's other studies,
so strict,
you know,
no sugar,
low calorie and yeah,
so those are the ones like,
so you want to get forced to die.
It actually,
you want,
you want to,
that's,
that's one of the major benefits.
So when people say like it's dangerous,
but like,
man,
I feel,
I feel so much better when you lose weight and be skinny.
It feels better.
Yeah.
So now,
I mean,
here's a question because you've done so many different teams.
You've had all these chemicals in you.
I mean at some point don't you think that the body is tampered with?
Like do you mean like he's not pure specimen anymore for us to test a Tabula
Rasa so to speak,
you're,
you're kind of tainted goods by only feel like that feel like,
you know,
I had this conversation two years ago in Vegas and this,
I don't remember his name at the Party and he was telling me,
Oh my God,
I wouldn't live with that.
That's your stupid to do that.
That's too dangerous.
And he was telling me while he was ready to snort coke so everyone have a
different idea of what's dangerous.
So you're right,
I mean I,
I can't tell you if I would have never gone to this business versus now that I'm
taking a two version of Yoshi is,
which one would have been the health.
Oh No,
I'm not saying that.
I'm just saying that.
I wonder if your body,
is it good to be the Guinea pig today?
Yeah.
Like it,
because you've done so many of these,
like at what point can you not do them anymore?
Because you've ingested.
So I see that
age,
you age restriction or I know just chemical restriction like because you like
they go,
thanks guys,
this guy has been tested on a hundred medications,
therefore you know,
that's like you can't do it.
And thing is like too many miles.
I'm not saying that I did it so then to it.
Yeah.
But many of these organizations don't talk to each other so they don't know what
he did.
I'll know.
So what happened is general rule is day way on Theo,
30 days before they contact you because it takes about two to three weeks for
their whole medication to get out of your system.
So to be safe on one month,
but there's times if you're broke,
you finished one study,
you drive across the town.
I'm not saying I did it.
Uh,
you could drive from one study to another study and you barely make it there and
do another screening.
I hop onto another studies,
but there's these group of guys,
uh,
I only do in Solo Caleb.
There's a group of guys,
it's like fight club.
They go literally city to city,
state to stay,
you know,
do studies all over the place.
I,
I'll see a guy's like,
oh,
I remember you at the 2014 liver cancer study,
what's up?
And then they'd call me why all for Yoshi Obayashi I don't remember the guy's
name,
km or whatever.
So that would be an issue for each other.
But um,
so there's a circuit and you know all the players and a lot of them.
Yeah.
I mean it's almost like when will you go in if you go in for this one,
the,
I think they're going to call me within the next,
uh,
seven to 10 days for screening.
Then after they do the testing,
well first they make you read the
document,
legal documents.
Tell him you just page through that,
right?
Yeah,
I have to re well,
yes.
Only there's only one facility that test you because if they,
if you filled out tests,
they know that you didn't read it and then they'll disqualify for other places.
Other places,
they don't give a shit.
There's one particular,
is that there so shady.
Even if you get caught doing something wrong like get out of the room,
talked to another person,
Redo the interview second time around to pass it.
They will do stuff like that.
I'm not going to tell you which one cause I need now when you were,
you were just doing a European tour with Jim Norton?
Yeah,
I just happened to be there for um,
Oslo Freedom Forum for like a okay men,
right stuff.
Do you happen to be there?
I'll having to be there.
Then his manager who we're not going to talk about it but contact you as well.
He asked me could you help Jim seal tickets or you know where it's a good place
to visit.
I just happened to be in the same week when he was performing,
so by default ended up open for him and it wasn't.
It was great.
I'm glad because there's a lot of comedians that you guys are such an open
minded people.
I know you don't have a fear of going overseas and doing comedy,
but there's a lot of funny people in the,
in America during standup.
I'm one reason that they don't like going overseas so they have this irrational
fear but I dunno,
they just don't go for some reason he donated by it or something.
Yeah.
And I'm glammed Jim Derek cause shame did extremely well.
And uh,
Bahrain who is our tour manager,
he was in charge of Public Francisco,
fluffy and Belbor and he told us basically Jim Soda,
same amount of tickets belbor first year he went to Europe.
It was very successful and Jim,
it was good exposure to see a side of this country is such a good comic though.
And surprise me on top of it.
Now at the g there's at any ladies of the night when you were touring,
you are so perceptive.
When we,
when we were in what I guess
when we went to Antwerp to do a show afterwards,
Jim want to go and check it out.
Uh,
Jim has never been to those places and he wouldn't do it because it's too low
class cause he get,
he get the high end first class,
you know,
I'm the southwest of Hooker,
pick up outweighs.
He is like,
you know,
first class,
Lufthansa,
whatever.
But um,
so we went to the one in Antwerp and a,
it's a midsize level one and um,
it was really good.
And what kind of prostitutes there?
Where are they from?
Mostly Eastern Europe,
but uh,
but I do notice last couple of years because European economic crisis you do
every once we'll see like,
wow,
you're German or your Dutch and Greek and Spanish,
Spanish,
Spanish people and Brexit.
That's probably doesn't help.
I mean there's,
there's,
there's fear in Europe about all the changes,
not just terrorism,
but,
um,
job wise,
you know,
and um,
I don't think Jim got a girl,
but what I was surprised that every window with transsexual lady,
I mean,
they look so good.
Like I can't even tell I have relived men.
Jim was hundred percent knew right away.
Like,
I dunno how he does it.
I mean,
I'm putting,
knew that that was a shemale that Shimo mushy meals.
I forget.
There's no,
no one,
I can't afford it.
But now that's not,
never been in mind.
Is that a premium they cost more?
Yeah.
Really?
Why?
Why wouldn't you think that?
Cause I just don't know why.
Um,
I don't know what they cost more and I guess considered more exotic.
So it's,
I think so.
Wow.
And well,
I mean it,
it seems like their prices are a lot higher than other ones,
you know?
Wow.
Not The black ones though.
Those cheaper.
They are the best of both worlds.
The transsexual,
I imagine.
Sure.
That's why it's like a bonus features.
And when did
you do that interview with,
with London Real Linden Real TV?
That was,
was that on this trip?
Wait a minute.
I don't remember this one.
I thought because someone said that you did this interview,
now you get a pass out.
Yeah.
You'll pull the skin.
A lot of people,
they never circumstances.
Yeah.
So they had to skin.
So you food the skin and you get the oil in the hand and your right hand gold
ids.
Do Rob,
Rob,
rob,
especially on the glans penis rubbed them 50 times rest.
Okay.
Because you met them strong and not sensitive.
So that's world famous.
Tom Blue,
right?
Remember Tom Boo?
No,
I sure don't remember.
maybe this is southern California.
Then there was a Vietnamese guy selling real estate scam and you it,
and then he's on the boat with all this white women around him and the Bikini's
and it was like,
who's that guy with the big hair?
The teaching people painting.
Um,
oh.
It was that level of cult following,
Tom Wgu.
Oh,
I can't believe you know.
T o n Space V as in victory.
Double Tom though.
I never heard it.
Oh my God.
Now he's like a famous poker player.
This guy,
Oh yes.
Videos or I can't.
I remember that guy.
You're from southern California,
right?
I can't believe you don't know him
by financially.
Then do the rest of y'all got some old shit right here though.
Transactions with a check for 15,000 this is really old and 50 remember this?
I took the time.
Boom profit seminar worked for me and it made me financially secure.
Why is he squinting?
You can do it too.
Oh no,
he's struck.
Don't have to ask your boss for a raise anymore.
You can give yourself the best race of your life.
Come to my seminar,
rob,
I have a crab or a technique does look like the rubber up guy made $33,000.
Wow.
If I can apply the top of your techniques and $33,000 on this house,
you can do it.
Proud of my seminar is a solution without the page using the Tom Lutein Dad,
maybe $12,000.
We don't need this shit.
My sister,
a lot of my students who I am makes people a lot of money.
Why not you?
That's dude.
What year was that?
That was like the 84 85 stupid.
I remember Tom do now.
I can't believe you didn't know Tom Wgu.
Wow.
That she makes me laugh.
Rob.
Rob,
thank you.
Rice.
Recite people time from the time back.
50 time Dow SayWhat okay.
How often am I doing this?
Do you have to do every day until you can control every day.
She's a,
what is it?
What are they talking about?
Well,
he's just talking about,
um,
sharpening the knife.
He calls it.
Oh.
And it's like master control of your orgasms,
you know,
are just so many pressure.
Like I said,
I don't have to be here.
Exercise.
I say Simon and fall.
People have prospect land stolen or problem.
This one who solved the problem and now you're doing until you feel,
okay,
so this is it here.
Oh yeah.
Cause where you can't grow without ejaculation,
right?
Yeah.
So you feel,
so you see when you do,
when,
when you get it,
it's very quick to two times.
You can
just all guests,
I'm coming up.
This is a different variation of Tai Chi touch me.
So yeah,
you could do the 50 50 50 rubs.
No Way.
Right?
5,350 is what do you edit up 350 strokes every day so you can control it.
I mean Rocco can do that.
The rest of us can't.
Freddy's the king hard to Rocco lately.
Do you know him personally?
No.
Last time I heard it from him,
it's when Joyce Rivera called me in Boston when I was doing shows there and he
wasn't going with Bronco and say Runco Save.
I'm sad to hear that you don't work at evil angel and I hope you're doing well.
So they're,
they're nice people and,
um,
he's such an animal.
I kid,
I laughed thinking about like I imagine over the years in my mind,
conversations he has with his wife who's like,
she's like,
when is enough of this potent,
I do it for the fans.
We pay the bills.
How am I going to make any money?
Hey,
you know,
it's not even for me.
It was kind of enraptured by your dreams.
I do it for them.
I know.
You know what's interesting,
he released a documentary.
We didn't launch a year or two about his sex addiction problems when we played
the,
uh,
the trailer love to,
and we watched that.
I Dunno,
I dunno.
I'm fascinated by him actually at a Russell Peters taping a few years back.
I had a Rocco came to that stage,
cons,
I backstage conversation with Rocco and I don't remember this.
So you met at the Wiltern now?
I think Tom was anyways.
Um,
and I met him and we had a really good personal conversation.
He told me about it.
Some childhood stuff.
No,
I swear to God he's super cold cause he knows I was Hungarian and his wife was
Hungarian.
He loves all Garren girls.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Anyways,
I really like him as a human,
but you know what
and he's such a funny guy.
Did I tell you that one time he was so disappointed that he was telling me that
I don't know these kids,
he was talking about his like uh,
nephews and stuff.
Like I don't know what's going,
what the fuck's wrong with his kids?
None of them went into get into porn of and all they ever talk about video
games.
He was complaining about video games,
social media and uh,
you told me that sometimes that that passes through my head as such a hilarious
dialogue that somebody like sign
16 now it's your turn to make a partner in.
The kid's like,
I want to play grand theft auto.
And he's like,
no,
but 16 is pardon the time.
And the kid is like,
but I just want to play video games dad.
And he's like,
what is wrong with these boys?
I think sets that,
I think I didn't,
I haven't seen the documentary,
but if you've ever been completely like being real about it.
Yeah.
When you're in that business,
so you have a drug addiction and whatever the addiction is because you have a
something missing,
you don't life intimacy,
right.
Because yes,
it's interesting with porn you're doing most intimate thing,
but it has so little intimacy in it,
you know.
And uh,
it's for people who are consuming it with PR personnel issues,
a lot of them,
you know,
and like if you're one of those people to watch every once in a while,
fine.
But if you always need it,
it's because there's something wrong with you.
I'm not attacking the business.
What do you think what you're saying is intuitive?
It's like you're,
you're,
you're spot on drug addiction or alcohol or porn or that the interview is about
the documentary,
cause I remember that we,
we read it on the show that he had retired from performing and then he was,
you know,
but that he was still going to hookers three times a day.
That's a,
and that his wife at some point I was like,
just go back to shooting again.
This is crazy.
It's not unlike a orgasm.
There's some,
some,
I'm sure there's some kind of trauma that you learn to sex or drugs or whatever
to give you a comfort,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
The traumas for sure.
Yeah.
That's why I think,
um,
one of the director Johnny Darko,
he's always like shocked.
Like,
I know you guys,
he's such a big fan.
Look,
I think you'll get it.
Okay.
Oh,
this is going to be in Italian with French
called Rocco.
And I kept bugging out.
Okay.
1500,
500,000.
The
appropriate
security,
they
go to work for me.
Now what they say
and why you can
start
right away.
But there were,
there was a funny
scene where one of the girls that my dad is a big fan of yours,
really think he's started fucking her and like,
okay,
and he's fucking a dog is down now.
Look at the camera and say hi to your daddy and Nike's fucking her and like
that.
So he,
he,
um,
did you see any hookers and Antwerp?
You're saying I find a new place.
I was really shocked.
Oh,
so please do tell.
Okay.
Does it does even shocking to me.
So I finished the show working with June.
Fantastic.
He was great at the audience of wonderful and talk about your fans.
You got your fence,
listen to this show because there's so much intimacy and make people really
happy.
I'm like I was saying Johnny Darko,
one of the director,
he's a big fan of yours and like he was really happy to him on the shoulder
time.
So anyway,
great job for the,
um,
after the,
after that comedy tour I flew into Athens,
Greece because one of my friend was working at the refugee camp.
So they live these people just fuck a refugee.
No,
no,
no.
But it's funny you say that because I do have some,
um,
so there's a place go city plaza hotel.
It was abandoned and a pro refugee group took it over.
I don't know how many,
maybe 500,
800 refugee people living there.
And my friend was working there as a volunteer and,
um,
when I showed up,
uh,
he was known he timing was bad so he couldn't be there.
So I just kind of walked around,
check it out.
And um,
rob,
I guess.
Yeah,
to city,
the city of Athens,
they don't want to deal with the refugee problem.
So they have a lot of refugees already.
Yeah.
Albanians are there.
And Syrians,
again,
fucking Gypsies.
Oh you sound like a northern Europe dinner and they treat them real bad so they
don't want to acknowledge it.
And the people who run it don't want to bother the city either because they're
so,
they're pretending it's not happening.
So anyway,
I kind of went there even though my friend wasn't there,
check it out and they're doing good job,
but it just shows like even if I have a good intention,
my mind go to the dark places.
Right.
Cause I saw really good looking Syrian girls walking and then what pops in my
head was I wanted to show,
give me a blowjob for hot dog.
Right.
Then the hot dog thing because there were,
I didn't do anything Tom,
but,
but those thoughts,
sue entered my mind.
I do not blame you for those thoughts.
I think those are normal thoughts.
I don't,
you just don't do it.
Don't do it.
Yeah,
you just don't do it.
Or you think she blamed me for a hot dog.
I think that on a,
on a regular basis,
like at the grocery store,
I'll be like,
I wonder if I got her groceries.
She gave me a blowjob in the parking lot or something like that.
Anyways.
But you didn't see any actual prostitutes paid for?
No,
but in Athens,
I didn't know that prostitution is legal.
So,
um,
I was there for three days.
So by lay first night I was bored because it's hot.
And then I just said,
did an internet search,
did not find out that
instead of red light district,
it's called why light district white light.
So it's called wildlife district.
So prostitution legal,
but you can't have a,
um,
pimp representing you,
but it's legal and unemployment for young people between 18 through 30 is
hovering almost 50%.
Jesus.
That's terrible.
But it's great for prostitution.
Yes.
So we should go there.
So I get someone to piss on my balls and put a baseball bat and her ass for you
like you like wow.
That sounds like Bella Donna.
Um,
it is like Bella.
Donna.
That's exactly what I was thinking of.
I like her.
She's great.
I've met her before.
This is the most pro porn podcast.
Christina's version of who?
My second wife.
She thinks that that I'll be over the family thing and I'd be like,
I just want some chick to piss on my balls.
Yeah.
Wait,
wait.
Is that something you're really into?
No,
no.
No.
Okay.
She thinks it's a rip,
like it's more of a metaphor for like letting out.
Whatever's repressed because I'm a family guy now.
I just feel like you're going to get also the fame.
We'll get to you and the banality of your everyday existence will weigh on you
and see where it,
and then you'll,
you'll be like,
I just want someone to pee on my balls,
but I can't ask my wife because I'm cheating.
Of course.
Wait,
what?
Peter's balls is cheating.
Why?
If you see someone's coach and somebody says it's a girl,
she mails.
Would they be upset?
That will be even more upsetting.
I think really well cause it's both.
Both a sexist cheating.
It's like a superhuman pee on my ball.
No Babe,
can I have someone pee on my vagina?
Yeah.
No,
it's fun.
Ips On my tank.
If that's what you like,
go for it.
I figured like if that,
if that's all they need to do,
then you're probably in your happy.
I'd be like,
good,
go get that piece.
Go get that p you want on your taste so bad.
You know in Athens I was there 10 15 years ago now and the dudes were holding
hands.
They still do that.
I didn't see that.
That's a Middle Eastern Muslim.
That's where maybe that was it.
Yeah.
Maybe I saw those dudes and they carry their beads around and the handholding.
Yeah,
they did.
They have a very weird notion of personal space,
but it,
but with men.
With men,
but they don't like when a women with a man,
unless you're married or something.
Yeah.
It's very good.
The Muslim world.
Yeah.
Um,
but no hookers and Antwerp,
you're saying?
Oh No,
I got to,
yeah.
Well let's talk about those.
No,
but the aunt Athens is amazing because while I districts,
so basically you go into this certain streets that they tow it there illegal,
you walk down the street,
even during the daytime they had this really tiny,
bright white light.
That means there's a prostitute there and the doors are wrapped with this,
uh,
um,
cloth.
So when,
when you close the door doesn't slam the door.
So you go in,
it's all,
you go in,
it looks like a disco room.
What this shiny things are going in a circle.
Like,
wow,
this is weird.
You sit down and usually there's another guy said into,
so you're standing there and waiting for a long time.
And that cousin in Athens,
Athens,
so like,
but like what,
what does it happen?
What happened?
And this is so,
it's such a strange then,
then,
then Dave literally,
literally cold their Mama Zone.
So she'll,
they're all women while in okay.
And she'll speak.
If she see a foreigner,
then she'll speak in Greek and English.
She said normal sex only.
I don't know what that means.
Normal sex.
10 year olds.
Like what the fuck?
What?
10 Euros.
If you don't know the cheese at 10 year olds?
No,
no,
no.
10 year old.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
It's what,
how much is it now?
$11 10 50 $10 and 50 cents.
That's how bad the euro is.
I didn't,
so wait a minute.
How did you close it back up?
How'd you end up at this place?
Like how do,
how does,
how do you end up there?
They said that,
I don't remember the name of that Shit.
They said like this,
these are the couple of streets are there.
They're legal to go.
Oh,
okay.
So I walked down the street,
but there's no science in hookers.
Right.
Even if even if it did,
then it's in Greek so I can read that.
Yeah.
So as I started walking,
like after awhile you start seeing only guys in the neighborhood.
Yeah.
I think going back and forth to these rooms,
like,
oh,
um,
so I noticed a pattern like white lights,
middle doors with the cloth.
So when he slammed me,
it doesn't make a lot of towns.
So I opened the door,
I go in and it's like a disco.
Right,
right.
So when the,
then she said when after she said 10 euros,
normal sex,
then what?
Then a girl walks in across the room from one door to another and you see them
for a second.
Oh,
so you get to it like I have all the goods.
Yeah.
And um,
the first one that I went there,
I mean she must've been 60 years old and old.
Like,
what the fuck?
I'm not doing this.
So like as I'm leaving,
she was assistant to gimme a kiss,
like being friendly.
Like I don't mean,
I don't want to be rude,
but she was so friendly,
but like,
you know,
she,
I was just making funny faces.
She came and just kissing me in the lip.
Like,
oh my God,
just talking about that.
When strangers wanting to kiss you on the mouth,
like they time you want to,
I'm not even
j a romantic thing and some people do,
but she wasn't being nasty.
But she was [inaudible] I don't want to hurt her feelings because she's
probably,
it doesn't make unless you're into like older,
overweight.
Wait,
was that your only option?
No,
no,
no.
So I left there,
but I was like,
Oh man,
this is,
I don't know if I want to do this,
but there's so many rooms and so many buildings,
so I just walk everyone.
And then eventually I went to,
I went to one door and um,
she was pretty,
so like I still that it's a scam because,
okay,
10 year olds,
but once you go in,
she going to say,
okay,
if you want this now the five,
if you want,
that's another 20.
That's what I thought.
And then,
um,
so if the guy doesn't like the girl,
they leave and they go to another building.
So like,
okay,
I like that one.
So like I'll pay for this one.
And um,
I get,
uh,
give the old lady 10 year olds and then,
um,
she grabbed me,
took me to this room and it's like a room with very basic furniture's with bed.
So you're just setting and every once in a while you hear high heel walking by.
So she's going back and forth and I guess every building with one door,
one girl only.
So he's just way on channel term.
Oh Man.
So you just wait and I think I weighed like half an hour for this one and she
came in and um,
we'll describe her.
She is
eastern European but I think she was a little darker,
so I think she's probably like Bulgarian or something.
One of those or Macedonia or something like that.
And um,
she didn't speak a whole lot of English,
but she,
she,
she relatively like,
I dunno,
late twenties are there,
who needs this make a lot of English when you're just making sweet love though,
right.
That's free lap.
She'd say 10 minutes,
normal sex and like,
oh,
they didn't,
you know,
like taking like you have to finish with everything by 10 minutes,
you know.
But if she says that like that's what she leads with.
Yeah.
Because if it's crazy,
I'm sure she learns to speak to them in Greek or whatever.
But um,
yeah,
it,
I was shocked.
It's only 10 euro fall that I could not believe.
And if you look you could find gem and um,
there's other ones.
Then after a while you see a really pretty ones,
but they all have rules.
Like,
no,
let gain though this and that ate the ass and pussy all the time.
I got nothing.
So did you get to do that though or no?
Um,
some of the gross won't let you do it.
Really?
Yeah.
But happy to compliant 10 euros though.
Yeah,
true.
I mean 10 years you get maybe a couple of dances that you are actually having a
blow job and then a couple of possession,
10 minutes.
Good for you.
As I was enough.
I mean it's,
if tenure,
you can't complain,
so you just got to finish it as you know.
I know.
I just like doing it.
They just like,
just like doing stand up,
you know,
you know when the red lights you have two minutes ago,
if he paid her 20 zero cause you double your time or is that not even an option?
You could pay somebody for like 64 whole hour if you want it to.
But there's,
but there's other streets,
it's like gross a 20 year olds.
There's others,
the studio and like fucking for 10 times.
And then did you have to wear a condom?
Was that Oh yeah.
God,
I hope so.
I mean,
here's the thing.
Anything is negotiable.
If you say you want to pay them 104 no condoms,
I mean the,
you will find a girl who will do it.
That is a crazy gamble or,
or,
um,
but it's $100.
They ain't know what I mean.
Or,
um,
no condom.
Blowjobs or,
you know.
Yeah.
I mean depends,
but everything's negotiable,
you know,
and,
but a lot of the girls are telling me there's guys that don't want to have sex
and just want to spend with a time with a group.
Those are the guys I would take if I were a prostitute.
I mean,
just give me your lonely.
Yeah.
Or snuggling
or some other girls in like,
oh,
she had to do is watch him eat for like an hour
eating.
Yeah.
What about farting?
Have you encountered anybody that just wants a girl to Fart or,
yeah,
let's talk about it.
Where did,
where did you encounter that?
I mean,
I talked to,
when I get to know that some of the girls still tell me weird stuff or date.
The,
another big thing is like,
they like gross sitting on cake and shit like that.
Okay.
Farts.
Or just sitting.
Just sitting on food.
Yeah.
Tom and I have started a website called fart mistress where we would lose Breo.
Yes.
Israel.
Uh,
we're not sure how we're going to get
this to happen,
but we've come across the spark videos where it's just girls farting and there's
nothing sexual happening.
Like,
do you know girls that do fart videos?
Like they just fart for like $100 or,
I mean if you paid them deal with do with any,
right,
but just,
I don't know any like you,
if you're asking me like certain girls have for prolapse and certain girls are
doing for a strip strap attack,
um,
sharp on attack.
I mean there's some girls a name attached to certain fetish,
but I don't know any famous girl interrupted
how is in the,
everything just dying was dropped and masturbating when his penis has dropped
and he slaps it on his belly.
They call that masturbation for stallions.
And so I just,
I,
one thing led to another and I couldn't resist,
so I bet down and started sucking on him.
That's right.
Horse.
Hey,
this documentary.
Then he tried climbing on top of me.
So the next thing I know my pants are down and I'm bending over for him and I'm
like,
excuse me,
I can't resist.
Hmm.
Uh,
a guy who was the guy that worked for Boeing got killed in his day.
That's right.
That was that documentary was about that.
Yeah.
Good.
Excuse me.
I can't resist.
Yeah,
you shouldn't fuck with animals.
They'd write and can't give consent.
I don't think that's fair.
Yeah.
They can't say anything.
We haven't discussed this yet.
Are Kelly posted?
You know,
he's in some shit now.
Well,
he's always in shit.
Yeah.
He,
this,
you know,
he's somebody who has really been able to navigate the horrible press.
Probably better than most.
I mean,
I remember the either the Chicago Tribune or the Sun Times did this expo is a,
a while ago.
Yeah.
Really laying out all the complaints that were in a Chicago courthouse.
Basically every filing that's ever been made as a complaint on him.
And it was like,
they were like,
look,
this is the record setting number that then that,
that didn't get any attention.
Everybody
always knew about that video with the pissing and,
well don't you think it has a lot to also to do with the victims.
They are victims but there are black women,
black women who are usually,
and they're young teens are not like talking about if,
if the narrative was,
if it was a young white girl,
I think,
I think reaction,
we've quite different at any ski.
Never pretend like it was a wholesome family guy either.
No.
Well here this is not,
hey it's fucking talented.
I don't like like he does.
He is unbelievable.
Those,
those lyrics.
Now they're saying that he's got women hold up in different houses and that's
bizarre.
Takes away their phones and just basically keeps them and tells them when to eat
window babe when you know it's like it's,
it's pretty nuts.
This is the,
the latest accusation.
This is separate from that.
But this is,
and I would drink from her lipstick car because,
and a son my,
the way I had a serious,
serious crush on my mom because she could sing her butt off.
Okay.
So you had a crush and I just looked up and down to her.
I looked around,
I looked everything about my mother,
you know,
I loved,
um hmm.
And I even asked her to marry me one day.
I was like,
Nah.
She said no,
but you know what?
I understood it.
I understood,
but don't you think he's being very honest about it?
I think it is just like the gays.
Um,
cause remember I think last time I told you at the live show asked him,
will you ever date your mom?
Yeah,
yeah.
That when I did your live show,
um,
you know,
porn have incredible ability to predict what's gonna be next president.
But Trump,
I think I kind of admire him being so honest about,
you know,
the,
the new trend is taboo relations or incest porn or those sorts of really popular
right now.
And you're saying,
I think that,
I mean the way he was talking about,
oh,
his daughter.
Yeah.
Like if she,
if she wasn't my daughter over day her,
you know,
but uh,
yeah.
And I even asked her to marry me,
asked him,
were you ever date your mom?
The incest,
anyone this show.
It's really another level.
But he really was,
I mean I understand what you're saying is kind of creepy the way that Trump
talks about it,
but it is I guess,
honest to kits on both sexist go through that in the Freud even talked about
that,
right.
Oedipus complex but also girls for their father.
You just,
when you reach a certain age you just outgrow that.
But some people obviously don't,
you know,
I think Levi Strauss,
the philosopher or entrepreneur,
that whole notion of taboo started with the whole idea of taboo and not have sex
with family related.
You know,
cause um,
because before then it wasn't I guess a big deal.
I mean people married cousins all the time,
like royal family.
It's,
some cultures still really marry their cousins.
Yeah.
FDR,
you know,
I mean there are four to five,
remove your something,
but they're nevertheless family.
And uh,
I remember reading this article one time in England when I was visiting.
Um,
there was a nuclear plant or something.
You're one of the cities in England and they were having all kinds of,
uh,
medical and biological problem with like,
um,
data.
It was some kind of radiation leak or something,
but when they did a little bit memory research,
they find out it was like incest,
um,
you know,
just family members having sex with each other.
It wasn't a nuclear plant.
So it happened more often than you think it does.
And in look at Utah,
there is a renegade Mormons,
the Mormon Church Jetson not condone it,
but there are people still multiple wives and you know,
there's all these weird things that happened.
I don't get it.
I mean like as,
as a parent now,
like that's the fucking last thing I could even fathom is like,
it's just not on the table.
It's looking for a lot of health problems with that health problems,
with the,
with the genetic problem,
you know,
with,
actually I heard the,
I heard cousins are okay,
I did professor in college.
I did,
I did.
I had a professor in college say that cousin fucking is not,
uh,
it's not the genetic mutations.
It's,
it's immediate like when you're going farther
or jotters genetic problems with cousin's cousin.
Fucking definitely.
Well definitely we'll have to see you look,
look at the studies.
There's loose studies out there about the cultures that have the most cousin
marriages and reproduction and is just ramp and health problems and,
and just like dogs,
same thing and just cross breeding,
breeding and inbreeding and yeah,
and I think,
was it Germany?
There was a case where these fraternity brothers,
sisters separated.
They didn't even know other existed and some at some really weird coincidence
against their met,
never knew they were related and they start having a relationship and you know,
uh,
yeah.
What are you doing that situation?
I mean it's a sexy story,
but yeah,
still
it's a very sexy story.
I go retarded retarded at that point.
I'd rather be retarded then have sex with my brother.
[inaudible] would you rather,
how about
this though?
Sorry,
this is regards to the last podcast,
this email.
Hey Hitler.
During the opening episode of four Oh five,
you guys discussed the pleasure of orgasmic birth as a man.
I have no idea what childbirth feels like,
Bro.
I'm willing to take these women's word for how great childbirth feels.
Christina has tried to shoot down the idea,
but I feel like it's more likely that it's something is wrong with her.
Okay.
And these ladies are all lying.
Maybe horrible personality.
Is it a hindrance to the pleasure or possibly was her lack of hydration that led
to the painful experience?
Love the palm cash.
Okay.
Burnt his fat.
Nate.
Thanks Nate.
So well,
why don't you squeeze a out of your Dick Hall
and we'll talk about it.
Yeah,
I mean it was pure pain,
right?
Yeah.
Dude,
there's no,
listen,
these fucking dirty hippies are trying to say that a woman can have an orgasm
during childbirth.
Uh,
you know,
I have yet to meet a woman that that's really happened too.
I guess in theory it's possible,
but it ain't fucking probable.
I mean,
it is excrutiatingly painful and I had a fucking epidural and they could still
feel it.
So no,
nothing sexy.
Yeah.
[inaudible] um,
somebody email about male to female pilots.
Hey Champs.
I heard you guys speculating on the female pilot situation.
Could we talked about uh,
uh,
flight I was on female was the yes.
And they said my spouse,
please use pronouns.
Pay Turd.
Tim and I was informed Taytay sees at least a couple applications each week for
a new pilots license due to a gender change.
Oh Shit.
And considering Tay is one of four people that handle these,
there has to be a pretty substantial amount of pilots that have changed their
gender.
Oh Wow.
Just thought you might like some verification on that point.
That's great week mommy,
your newest,
coolest fan.
Levi.
Okay.
Wait.
You know,
right away when you said it first,
a male to female po whatever.
I thought there was some kind of new sexual position so I was confused for
okay.
Yeah,
I know.
Female.
Um,
well I knows this says that Garth fucked up Ireland.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Um,
this person wrote,
hey jeans.
I love the Wheeler Walker Jr podcasts,
the live songs with great idea.
Uh,
your conversation about Garth being a moron.
I wanted to draw attention what happened a while back when g tried to play
Ireland's largest sports stadium Croke Park Wa I want to let you know that
Brooks is huge and in Ireland,
especially with mums and rural fork,
rural folk,
excuse me.
Uh,
the announcement of the gigs was a big deal.
Kid not played her 17 years.
Wow.
Personally,
I think his music is uttered cripe and maybe slightly good if you're really
hammered at a wedding,
the promoters and Garth teen book,
five consecutive nights in the stadium,
something which has never happened before.
Tickets for a release and sold out immediately.
Wow.
All 400,000 of them.
Oh my God.
The stadium is in a densely populated residential area and concerts often cause
of major disruption.
For this reason,
there is a rule,
no more than three concerts can happen in a row and one week within the stadium
when this was announced by the council and government,
Garth responded by pulling all the show what Santa does,
saying it's all or none.
It basically caused a national emergency shit.
The Irish prime minister,
tee shot ended up having to make a statement in parliament about the whole
fiasco.
It was all anyone talked about.
He acted like a total total spoiled Brat.
Everyone here was appalled by him.
I live in Belfast and knew about 10 people who were devastated.
Here is a BBC news article about the whole thing.
Love all the way from Belfast,
Ireland.
Wow.
Kiva O'CONNELL.
Wait,
so sorry.
Yeah,
fucking a man.
So they did cancel.
He did counsel.
It sounds like he did.
I mean cancel because he said it's all the shows are none and I guess that is a
good position to have as a portfolio if you're,
if you're traveling abroad,
I think it's,
and for the sake of the fans,
you can't,
who are you going to decide who gets to see the show?
How are you going to decide,
you know which night and which,
which nights are people going to get screwed on?
That's not cool.
How would he do that?
I guess,
right?
And like how would he choose?
That's what I'm saying.
So he's probably,
it's actually a smart,
but that's crazy.
They wouldn't let him.
Cool stuff.
Slick stuff.
Neat stuff.
Garth Brooks,
are you,
did you,
did you know that the country music was so big and in Northern Ireland?
I would never have guessed.
I never would have guessed honestly.
This is how detached I,
I would've never,
I guessed that he is of this level of popular everywhere.
No,
I mean I knew he was a star.
I didn't have any doubt about that.
But like when I was in
Edmonton,
I was in Edmonton earlier this year and he was there.
He did nine arena shows,
bananas.
They like in her though in a row where the Oilers play,
they put a banner like where they put championship banners of Garth up there at
the end of the ninth show and they're like,
this is what an impact you just had here.
I mean,
you know,
we're talking,
he goes somewhere and does hundreds of thousands.
Sure.
Bigots.
I had no idea he was that big of a star.
You know?
I just knew he was a,
you know,
a big deal,
but not like that.
I mean,
I always say white people have feelings too.
And when people do
where people do,
and one thing we learned from Trump winning that there's been a group of people
that have been neglected and maybe,
I dunno,
I dunno his music by maybe he sings songs about people in a desperate situation
that excel can you give them comfort and he really connects with that.
Yeah,
I don't attack.
Hey Papa Concha.
I just,
I don't know music,
you know,
but if he is doing that and obviously he is good for him and um,
but that's just,
well,
Canada is not that surprising.
It is still North America,
you know,
but,
but all the,
this holy shit that he's sold out that stadium,
they couldn't keep the tickets.
That's crazy,
man.
I mean,
he's a very principled person because 400 how many,
how much is I?
Oh,
I'll be a whore.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's a lot.
I didn't hit him.
He doesn't need the money,
but he's going to take that money course.
Yeah,
he's got a feed.
Trish.
I'm just getting bigger every year.
Oh Man.
I think I'm you guy.
But
I love it.
I say it to to get your eyes to go wide.
Uh,
now that you guys are,
are,
are talking about blind people.
I got a short and simple question.
Yeah.
Do twin brothers have the same dick size?
I'm sure they know,
but I don't this,
I don't have a twin brother Frank.
Frank asked life mysteries.
Yoshi,
we,
that's a great question.
A great,
quite open.
Yeah.
We should call it urologist.
How could validate or just a twin.
A twin.
Okay.
We need,
we need someone that's an exact twin when call called,
he didn't say that.
Dead.
All right.
Well I'm assuming not fraternal twins are identical.
Yeah.
He said no,
I'm saying he didn't specify whether it was identical or fraternal in cause
there's,
there's obviously you can be,
I have no reason to say this,
but I would imagine if you identical,
you're identical with everything.
You,
I think so,
but a mirror.
I think that's what he's,
he's at.
But I'm assuming that the deck is the same size,
I'm assuming.
Do,
who can we call that the toy?
You have to find,
we know people that are twins isn't Ryan?
Ryan's a secular?
Yeah,
he's a twin.
Is He an identical or fraternal journal and then Nike.
Yeah,
but then maybe the question,
let me just see if I can,
it's interesting.
I'm a true thing to say about that one.
Um,
I don't know what study it was,
but each succeeding son,
you have the percentage of that kid being gay,
gay,
higher.
Really?
Yeah.
And then,
and another one was my friend Ogi Ogas who wrote a book called Billy and wicked
thought he's a professor at Harvard.
He said that,
um,
gay men in general have a bigger penis than heterosexual men by saying quarter
to a half inches.
I don't know where that's three company.
He's a scientist.
But yeah.
Is there a reason for it?
Do we know why?
Or a theory
maybe be,
well,
I mean,
most heterosexual people meant the one that matter,
but gay men are more sexually aggressive.
Oh yeah.
They fuck a lot more probably than straight guys.
That's why when they think they're sissy and stuff,
which is weird because their appetites way stronger than they fuck like crazy
and it's so readily now we also had debates about blind people.
Uh,
how do blind people know when they're done wiping?
Oh,
take a shit.
And there was a blind person know when they're done.
Especially black blind person because the,
the,
the well,
how would you know when,
when,
when does it begin and end?
I mean he's already to blinds.
I was already blind so yeah,
but they have a partner,
right?
That just because they are blind doesn't mean they're going to have a blind
partner either,
right?
No,
not so your,
your theory is that they caught me,
I don't know.
I mean the call the partner in and go,
hey,
tell me,
tell me when this paper is white again.
Is that what you think?
Yeah.
Or how does a very successful rich and powerful blind people know we've data and
go looking people
because they must have assist in like it should go.
Like how would you know?
You can feel,
they can feel your face.
They touch your face and your features and see if they're symmetrical,
but if you never seen their face before,
how do you know what's a good looking good?
I cemetery,
I'm guessing.
Okay.
Dad.
I'm guessing you can tell by features of the nose is like a cute button nose or
is it,
you know,
wonky or whatever.
I don't know.
This isn't going to Christina arena,
but you know that thing in Plato's republic that all the real objective standing
and there's a fire,
so that's three of the cave.
You she,
so they're seeing a shadow of something that has no real,
but to them it's real,
right?
Correct.
Until they go to the light of day.
Do you think the blind people they have in their head what's pretty phase,
even though they've never seen a pretty face ever before?
Yes.
You do.
Okay.
They have an ideal that's different than maybe yours or mine maybe.
I don't know.
They have,
they have different,
I'm having somebody that's never seen a face as an ideal of a pretty face.
Yes.
Yeah,
I think so too,
because there are other senses are heightened.
We've had blind people write in and it wouldn't match.
It wouldn't,
it wouldn't be maybe the same ideal as societal ideal,
but it would be an ideal in their mind.
Sure.
So we've had blind people write in and they say that the people know how to
finish wiping based on touch.
Okay.
This year your sensitivity to touch is heightened and you can feel the resist or
Helen killers.
Fuck.
Because she has no senses at all.
She was fucked.
She,
they taught her a good baseline of stuff though.
I don't know.
I think of that.
One of the things you would probably do if you were blind,
you would say,
you would ask,
Hey,
who's,
uh,
who's objective,
who's considered very beautiful?
Then you'd,
you'd learn with that.
There you go.
Then you'd be like,
this is beautiful.
This is beautiful.
Okay,
so because that would,
your sense of touch would be heightened and you'd have a memory of that.
You know,
that this is what,
it's a verb victims,
ugly.
Cause when you touch them,
they have a beef jerky face.
Right?
So beef jerky pace,
right.
Everybody's idea of what's beautiful is different.
I Dunno.
Sickler man,
he never responds.
He isn't.
He supposed to come on here and talk about the Hillary Clinton thing that he
didn't tell anybody about and then he uh,
he partied with her once I started to drop another book,
but there was a book called survival of beauty.
Beautiful professor named Nancy Act off wrote a book.
But she said there is definitely certain mathematical ratio of somebody being
absolute have full clarity propulsion.
And I know sometimes people say you shouldn't judge people by the book or
whatever,
but if you're living in third world countries,
it's important that you judge people by their face because you don't know if
they have leprosy.
You know,
these are the collect practical things.
Um,
it's just men.
We always do this.
We've judged women by the visual cues.
Yes.
Women more psychological cues.
Absolutely.
You know,
I'm looking for red flags.
You said that you had red immediately when we were dating
immediately.
This is a joke series.
I want to hear this.
I want to know.
I'm going to know what was the problem.
Tom's red flags.
Okay.
Number one.
I'm very antisocial.
I invited him to a party.
This is like right when we were kind of starting to date.
I go,
come to this party,
what's on our friends are going to be there.
He doesn't show up.
And then I see him around,
I'm like,
hey,
why don't you go to that party?
He goes,
oh,
I fell asleep.
So that was kind of weird that like
he shot goes.
Tom Always seem very social to me.
Really?
I don't think so.
And then when we started dating we were um,
you know,
it was a kissy face time and we're so in love and he was like,
I like you so much,
I just want to stab your eyes until they bleed.
I want to punch you.
I want to,
I want to just kill you.
Like he kept talking about wanting to murder me and stuff.
I would say things like,
I want to put your head through that dresser.
Right?
Yeah.
But I mean it was,
I said it like in a jokey.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it stole flag.
Yeah.
I just,
I turned it into it.
I turned to red flag into a pink flag cause I was like,
wow.
It could be a sense of humor thing.
Yeah.
We,
we're both comics.
So it was this past summer thing.
Yeah.
But there's,
there's still some shit under it and then you shouldn't have examined.
What changed though?
Obviously if everything worked out well it's 12 years later and towards more
normal and you know,
but um,
what changed?
I just got to know him better,
I guess.
Yeah.
Any other,
there's some other flags made me to this day.
Like what?
I'm talking to yourself a lot.
Like I love the,
this is two days ago I look over and he's literally going
like my,
like freaking out to himself and I'm like,
are you talking to?
He's like,
oh,
so and so I'm having a thing.
I do that a lot.
I do that a lot,
but I don't think that's that big of a red flag.
No,
I don't.
I don't,
my dad does it too.
So I,
I,
I've seen him do it so many times and it does make me either amuses me or I'm
like,
the fuck is wrong with you,
so I can only imagine.
So because,
gosh,
we don't care if you have a career or good credit,
we just look at your face,
uh,
the proportion of your body,
your breasts as,
but there's a genetic reason for that.
But women look at guys and say,
is he strong enough to protect my offspring?
As you have a social status?
Is he kind,
you know,
did you know these,
these things that really matters?
So guys just need a nice pair of tits and that's it.
Yeah.
It,
it is true,
but there's a reason that the fats are unimpressed and as is what necessary to
keep a baby very healthy.
And luckily for me,
she's got a couple of state troopers on it.
They're so big and droopy now.
They're not.
Oh my God,
they're destroyed.
Please destroyed.
All right.
Um,
what else?
Is there anything,
what do you got coming up,
which you got?
Um,
well,
I also went in Canada,
by the way.
I was banned for 12 years and 12 years,
the bandage usually seven or 10 years,
10 years.
But I was still afraid to go,
but I went up there for,
um,
how the,
they take care of addicts in Vancouver.
So I had to go after working with the Russell Peters in Portland,
so went up.
It was so embarrassing because when you go up in the buzz,
they can't continue to travel to travel to Vancouver.
And unless everybody get on or that you have to tell them,
this person gonna get back on and go to Canada.
So I was the last one to get in and I had to talk to three officers,
you know,
I have to explain the whole fiasco.
I happened,
but I went up there.
What was the initial band for like a fight or alcohol?
I was opening for Russell Peters,
but I had a bag of porn,
which is fine.
That's legal will come into bravo was run.
Does that time.
Michael Jackson got in trouble for second accusation molestation.
So in my notebook I wrote Michael Jackson's favorite child porn titles.
And so they find a bag of porn,
which,
how porn?
Titus data,
which is called top or no grapher shit,
you know,
kindergarten cock,
spongebob,
no pans,
hairless.
And Seattle,
Connie,
I fucked the kids where they are.
These are,
these are great comedians.
How did that turn into a band?
Well,
they took me to this room and when every one of those db and DVDs and I had to
stand in there for three hours watching porn with these three Canadian officers
because they were making sure there's no kid in there then,
but they have to get me for something.
And you know,
even if somebody here,
I was falsely accused of child porn,
my life is over.
Yeah.
So there's a,
I'm glad you think that's funny.
So is so over.
So
I don't know why that's so funny.
It wasn't funny at all.
Yeah.
It wasn't funny when that happened,
but um,
or you could just admit you're working for this guy,
would a work visa.
I said that I agree with that.
I don't care about now going to Canada for 10 years.
I'd rather take that.
But what was so funny,
not funny at the time,
but as he's typing my problems,
cause he said if you go to,
we could make it see a judge about your child porn even though there's no cad.
Yeah,
there's a job for,
and then Russell,
Peter called me have to,
hey,
it's in the shore.
It's a star now or where are you?
And I told him the situation and he goes,
well you deal with do with motherfuckers,
go fuck them Joe blow.
The guy heard him say that and I saw him like he paused and like delete whatever
he's typing and then retype something over nest.
So Russell think is funny,
but it wasn't fun.
I'm a was just terrifying,
you know,
and they're just going after peep and then they sent you back.
They let me do the show because there's no fly back that night.
So,
but they say first day in the morning you have to leave.
So I did a show,
um,
I did one show in them in turn and then I have to fly back.
So I went up there for,
um,
Canadian centering,
amazing job in Vancouver saving people because they have the only one on the
plays in Vancouver,
east hasting Vanda,
uh,
Vancouver Network of drug users or union or something.
Uh,
they were kind enough to invite me up there and,
uh,
I still about 80 people inject heroin,
but they're saving people's lives because they're no overdosing.
They have a community to,
to,
uh,
help people with a spirit of STD and a number of,
um,
overdose dropped crime drop and it's working.
And then we were trying to pass a similar measure in Seattle by didn't pass.
And uh,
um,
we lost a bunch of dear friends and acquaintance and comedy because of the
diction overdose and the policies that we have is,
it's terrible.
Yeah.
So are you going to,
you have any upcoming shows you,
oh,
yeah.
August 10th,
uh,
laughs on,
limited in Sacramento APM.
If it's the first,
um,
illegal comedy show,
illegal comedy.com.
And,
uh,
I'm sailing magazines after the show.
This is magazine.
You guys,
he gave us some August 10th.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
it's,
it's a great weekend because August 11 to 12,
you are doing show in Sacramento.
Punchlines,
right?
It's got to be a fun weekend.
So,
uh,
we were going to show video from the magazine until I knew exactly what I'm
doing.
I need to sell tickets because I'm already minus 600 is literally blood money
I'm paying.
So if no one shows up,
I'm fine.
Where's the,
where's it at?
Where's the laughs on limited.
Oh,
add.
Last Limited.
Okay.
Apm.
August 10th.
And um,
nobody where 11th in Phoenix or Glendale,
Arizona at the club.
Off the cuff,
we're doing another illegal comedy.
So I'm basically just break even to people that we want to help people to Adeq
drug problems.
And I'm great man.
I'm trying to go and dig up Canada to do a big show.
Hopefully,
maybe even have a Russell Peters hosting it.
But,
uh,
um,
we lost 67,
almost 70,000 Americans last year and the year before that 35,000.
So that is a massive,
dramatic,
sad.
We're losing.
These are the bad people.
I just want people don't the dcis or your brother,
sister,
uncle,
and even grandparents and our policies are hurting people.
It's misguided.
So,
um,
I want to hopefully save people's lives.
That's a very powerful message,
man.
I'm glad you're doing that and your fans are wonderful.
They're just a really nice big hit him up.
Hit Up Yoshi on Twitter.
You're at Yoshi Obayashi Dotcom and illegal comedy.com.
And um,
last was some limit in August 10th.
All right,
Jean,
anything else?
Ah,
no.
Thanks for coming here,
Yoshi.
We always love having you and your fans are just wonderful.
I mean,
I can't believe these couples listen to my horrible jokes are very sweet.
Thank you.
You're the best.
All right guys.
We'll see you next time.
Thanks for listening.
Come see Tom.
Yeah,
it comes on.
I'll be there.
Donald Ching,
Ching,
cha,
Ching.
Chong.
Want to fuck with my mind?
Why she got to have a career?
We had to send her flowers on a Tuesday.
Oh,
Anna Bay.
My Day because I make crazy as videos
that's been in my hair.
Fucking
dik
dik dik
dik dik in the wrong,
I can't
stand when somebody comment.
I know one of my video.
Hi.
No waterfall that I am blessed.